disregard any evidence for which I
sustain an objection and any evidence
that I order to be struck
anything you may have seen or heard
outside the courtroom is not evidence
and you must entirely disregard it
the lawyers might stipulate or agree to
a fact or I might take judicial notice
of a fact otherwise what I say and what
the lawyers say is not evidence
you are to consider only the evidence in
the case but you are not expected to
abandon your common sense you are
permitted to interpret the evidence in
light of your experience
instruction 12.
direct and circumstantial evidence
facts may be proved by direct or
circumstantial evidence the law does not
treat one type of evidence is better
than the other
direct evidence can prove a fact by
itself
it usually comes from a witness who
perceived firsthand the fact in question
for example if a witness testified he
looked outside and saw it was raining
or today it would be snowing
that would be direct evidence that it
had rained or snowed
circumstantial evidence is indirect
evidence it usually comes from a witness
who perceived a set of related events
but not the fact in question
however based on that testimony someone
could conclude that the fact in question
had occurred for example
if a witness testified that she looked
outside and saw that the ground was wet
and people were closing their umbrellas
that would be circumstantial evidence
that it had rained
instruction 13 believability of
witnesses
in deciding this case you will need to
decide how believable each witness was
use your judgment and Common Sense let
me suggest a few things to think about
as you weigh each witness's testimony
how good was the witness's opportunity
to see hear or otherwise observe what
the witness testified about
does the witness have something to gain
or lose from this case
does the witness have any connection to
the people involved in this case does
the witness have any reason to lie or to
slant the testimony
was the witness's testimony consistent
over time
if not is there good reason for the
inconsistency
if the witness was inconsistent was it
about something important or unimportant
how believable was the witness's
testimony in light of other evidence
presented at trial
how believable was the witness's
testimony in light of Human Experience
was there anything about the way the
witness testified that made the
testimony more or less believable
in deciding whether or not to believe a
witness you may also consider anything
else you think is important
you do not have to believe everything
that a witness said you may believe part
and disbelieve the rest on the other
hand if you are convinced that a witness
lied you may disbelieve anything the
witness said
in other words you may believe all part
or none of a witness's testimony you may
believe many witnesses against one or
one witness against many
in deciding whether a witness testified
truthfully remember that no one's memory
is perfect anyone can make an honest
mistake honest people may remember the
same event differently
construction 14 depositions a deposition
is the sworn testimony of a witness that
was given previously outside of court
with the lawyer for each party present
and entitled to ask questions
testimony provided in a deposition is
evidence and may be read to you in court
or may be seen on a video monitor
you should consider the deposition
testimony the same way you would
consider the testimony of a witness
testifying in court
construction 15 objections and rulings
on evidence and procedure
from time to time during the trial I may
have to make rulings on objections or
motions made by the lawyers
lawyers on each side of a case have a
right to object
when the other side offers evidence that
the lawyer believes is not admissible
you should not think less of a lawyer or
a party because the lawyer makes
objections
you should not conclude from any ruling
or comment that I make that I have any
opinion about the merits of the case or
that I favor one side or the other
and if a lawyer objects and I sustain
the objection you should disregard the
question and any answer
during the trial I may have to confer
with the lawyers out of your hearing
about questions of law or procedure
sometimes you may be excused from the
courtroom for that same reason
I will try to limit these interruptions
as much as possible please be patient
even if the case may seem to go slowly
instruction 16 statement of opinion
under limited circumstances I will allow
a witness to express an opinion
consider opinion testimony as you would
any other evidence
give it the weight you think it deserves
you may choose to rely on the opinion
but you are not required to do so if you
find that a witness in forming an
opinion has relied on a fact that has
not been proved or has been disproved
you may consider that in determining the
value of the witness's opinion
construction 17 charts and summaries as
evidence charts and summaries that are
received as evidence will be with you in
the jury room when you deliberate
you should consider the information
contained in them as you would any other
evidence instruction 18
charts and summaries of evidence
certain charts and summaries
sometimes referred to as demonstrative
exhibits will be shown to you to help
explain the evidence however these
charts and summaries are not themselves
evidence and you will not have them in
the jury room when you deliberate you
may consider them to the extent that
they correctly reflect the evidence
instruction 19 out of state or out of
town experts you may not discount the
opinions of an expert merely because of
where he or she lives or practices
construction 20 conflicting testimony of
experts in resolving any conflict that
may exist in the testimony of experts
you may compare and weigh the opinion of
one against that of another
in doing this you may consider the
qualifications and credibility of each
as well as the reasons for each opinion
and the facts on which the opinions are
based
instruction 21 questions from the jury
not permitted I want to give you an
instruction regarding questions from the
jury
the nature of a trial is that we take
one witness at a time
no witness can tell the whole story
you may have questions from time to time
that arise based on the testimony you've
heard so far
please be patient and wait to hear all
the evidence
sometimes information you need to decide
can only be presented by Witnesses who
may be called later in the trial for
that reason you should not start forming
opinions until after you've heard all
the evidence
also the parties have spent many months
a exchanging information and obtaining
it from third parties
they have been required to disclose to
each other as they proceeded what proof
they plan to present to you
to prove their side of the case
in some cases they have asked and
obtained rulings from the court
as to certain proof that may or may not
be offered
when the evidence is fully presented you
will have all of the information
necessary to make the decisions that you
need to make
that may or may not mean that all of
your questions are answered
sometimes the Rules of Evidence prohibit
the kind of additional information that
you think might be helpful
or sometimes the parties have chosen not
to present that evidence
in any event you must make your decision
based on the evidence presented to you
you should not speculate as to what
other evidence that might have been
presented might have shown
so that concludes the opening
instructions
are the plaintiffs ready to begin their
opening statement
yes your honor do you want us introduce
ourselves first yeah I neglected to do
that if you could please introduce who's
at your table and your client please
good morning my name is Robert Sykes
this is Lawrence Bueller he and I are
the co-lead council here we also have
Kristen Van Norman
and Peter Sorensen all together we are
honored to represent Terry Sanderson
here at the end thank you
and the defense
thank you my name is Steve Owens I'm
here in town a firm called well I should
say Salt Lake City at a firm called that
person in Owens this is James Egan
Noreen Abu Rama Peter Jensen and we're
all here for Miss Paltrow
thank you
Mr Bueller you may begin
distracted skiers cause crashes
defendant Gwyneth Paltrow
knew that looking up the mountain and to
the side Council you need to use a mic
it just uh it's right here
testing
very faint on them
your honor while we're doing that we
should be clear that no Witnesses at the
trial are permitted in this courtroom I
don't I'm not keeping track of everyone
but
the exclusionary rule applies
exclusionary rule will apply meaning
that anyone who will be a witness in
this case cannot sit in and listen to
the case before they testify so if
there's anyone here that's a witness
you'll need to leave the courtroom now
thank you
did we get it operating
okay
start again
ladies and gentlemen
still here oh well let's try this
okay
ladies and gentlemen
distracted skiers cause crashes
defendant Gwyneth Paltrow knew that
looking up the mountain
and to the side
while skiing down the mountain was
dangerous
and she knew that skiing that way
looking somewhere else
blindly skiing down a mountain by
looking up and to the side
was Reckless
and she knew if she continued to ski
that way
that it was not a matter of if but when
by looking up and to the side
it was not a matter of she would crash
into somebody below her and someone
would get seriously and permanently hurt
she knew what she was doing was
dangerous
she knew it was Reckless and someone
well
and somebody would get hurt anyway I
think I just said that but before we get
into the details of this case
of how Gwyneth Paltrow's neglect her
choices
and her conscious disregard for other
people on the mountain
all combined together
to cause Terry Sanderson to suffer four
broken ribs
permanent brain damage we first have to
talk how skiers are supposed to ski down
a mountain
what the rules of safety are
and the purpose for those rules and what
happens when skiers break those rules
that way we will all be on the same page
and we can get into the details of this
case okay
all skiers know that when they are
skiing down the mountain
it's their responsibility to pay
attention
look downhill
and yield the right of way to the skiers
below them
because the skiers below them can't see
behind them
to control
as they turn left and right
to control their speed
especially when there's multiple people
on the mountain
it's the uphill skiers
responsibility to yield the right-of-way
to those below
and it's never enough to say well so
what if I crashed into someone that was
below me on the mountain
that doesn't mean it's all my fault
because especially on a beginner run
they know that skiers may be less
experienced and the skiers below them
Trust
that the ones coming behind are paying
attention that's what skiers do
before they start down a hill they take
account of how many skiers are below
them
what those skiers are doing and they
keep their eyes forward down the hill so
they can yield the right of way
and even though it can be challenging
sometimes when skiers do these things
they get to enjoy skiing they get to
enjoy practice their skiing
and most importantly everyone gets to go
home safe at the end of the day and
that's a good thing
but some skiers say
well what's so wrong
with looking up the mountain
behind me and to the side while skiing
down the hill just because a crash
occurs
on the mountain with somebody that was
below me that doesn't mean it's my fault
and some skiers say well what if the
person below me on the mountain was
changing directions quickly
maybe it's their fault too and finally
they say look what's the big deal you're
not that hurt
and it's attitudes like this
Behavior like this
choices like these when crashes happen
and sometimes it's just a bump or a
bruise sometimes it's a scare or a close
call but sometimes it's worse sometimes
it's broken bones
sometimes a concussion or permanent
brain damage and that's exactly what
happened here
so let's get into the details of the
case
defendant Gwyneth Paltrow has skied
since she was three years old and
considers herself an intermediate skier
Miss Paltrow has skied about a half a
dozen times at Deer Valley Ski Resort
she hires multiple ski instructors
for her children which allows them to
skip the lines the private instructors
cost thousands of dollars per day
on the day of the Collision February 26
Miss Paltrow is skiing at Deer Valley
with nine people including her two
children her future husband Brad falchuk
his two children and four Deer Valley
private ski instructors
Eric Christensen is one of those private
ski instructors
he has worked for Miss Paltrow's family
for a handful of ski vacations in past
Seasons Eric Christensen
knows the family well enough that one
time he sent her son some pottery that
he hand makes
a few minutes before noon Miss Paltrow's
group of 10 meet at the top of bandana
ski run to go to the bottom
for lunch
bandana is a green run about three
quarters of a mile long
Deer Valley groom's bandana
every day every ski day skiers have
skied on it for three hours
the snow is packed although a green run
bandana is steep enough
for skiers to pick up speed unless they
make turns
slow signs are always at the top I'm
just going to show you a picture of that
real quick
this is not the actual ski day or the
event this is just an example of what
bandana looks like
okay so this is the top of bandana ski
run
these are this is not the day of the
crash but it's near the crash site and
as you can see the top of the lift is
where people get off and start to ski
and they come down and the rest of
bandana goes down about another half
mile or so
I just had one of Bob's Fisherman's
friends cough drops and it's a little
drier than I expected
also at the top of bandana is a meet-up
group of about six adults
a meetup group is a group that meets
online to engage in activities like
skiing
hiking
or bowling or many other activities
plain of Terry Sanderson is in this
Meetup Group
four in the Meetup Group
ski down four of those in the Meetup
Group
ski down first then Sanderson skis down
to the right
Craig Ramon
is another person in the Meetup Group
who skis about 35 feet behind Sanderson
Sanderson and Ramon know each other only
through skiing in this Meetup Group
so they're not really close friends but
they know each other
and they've only done about a half a
dozen of these meetup groups together
at the top of
of bandana
Miss Paltrow her two kids and their two
instructors
are ready to go down to the bottom of
bandana for lunch
before they ski one of Miss Paltrow's
children says
Mommy Mommy watch us ski okay
the children and their two instructors
ski to the left
and the the two instructors are Eric
Christensen and Carrie Oaks Miss Paltrow
skis down to the right
she turns her head up to look at her
children
as she turns her head back down she
screams
then skis that into the back of Terry
Sanderson
she rides his back down they hit the
ground hard
Miss Paltrow bounces off of Terry
the weight of both of them their bodies
cause
Mr sanderson's rib cage and his arm to
smash into the ground breaking four of
his ribs
two of them completely
sanderson's helmeted head
s the ground causing a concussion as his
brain strikes the inside of his skull
Sanderson is face down in the snow
unconscious
skiing 35 feet above them Craig Ramon is
the is the only eyewitness
to the uh of the crash Ramon skis down
and stops just next to them
he asks if they are okay if they are
okay they say nothing Ramona
again is the only witness of this crash
Miss Paltrow is slow to get up
her son's instructor Eric Christensen
skis over from the left
and stops above Sanderson and screams at
Sanderson who is not moving
what did you do what did you do
surprised by the crash and Christensen
yelling at Sanderson Ramon thinks why is
this Deer Valley guy screaming at
Sanderson
he didn't cause this Collision
Christensen doesn't let up so Ramon
steps between them
Christensen stops yelling at Sanderson
Sanders sin is still not moving they
asked Sanderson if he is okay but
Sanderson only groans
Craig Ramon turns to Paltrow are you
okay
he asked several times
are you okay
she doesn't say a word and she slides a
few feet down the hill
Terry moves a little and groans
my ribs
Paltrow turns away and bolts down the
mountain to the bottom
Christensen turns to Ramon
do you realize your buddy just took out
Gwyneth Paltrow
Sanderson moves more trying to get his
skis around Eric Christensen steps
closer to Sanderson
picks him up by his hands and stands
them up
snow is caked in
sanderson's goggles
Christensen turns his skis
down the mountain and he bolts
skiing straight to the bottom following
Paltrow's group leaving Sanderson and
Ramon alone at the crash site
Sanderson is standing but hunched over
mumbling
and Ramon says do you think you can ski
think so
Sanderson tries but skis poorly
Ramon says stop stop you forgot how to
ski
do you know your name
Terry
do you know where you are
I have no clue
Ramon says let me get some help and
Ramon steps back
and flags down a Deer Valley employee
and says can you get ski patrol here
this guy's been hit
he's hurt
and he's just out of it disoriented
Smith excuse me within minutes a Deer
Valley Ski patroller Whitney Smith
arrives with a sled
Smith examined Sanderson puts him in a
sled and takes him down to the first aid
station at the bottom of bandana
at the first aid station
Sanderson again is evaluated and he
still has some disorientation
his ribs hurt
Whitney Smith tells him
and as uh the group of people in the
Meetup group that are with them he needs
to go to an InstaCare in Park City
Terry goes to the InstaCare with someone
who drives him uh he's not sure who it
was
and at the InstaCare he's evaluated
but the InstaCare says you need to go to
an ER room
uh his uh it looked appeared that his
pain in his ribs might be broken and he
still had or he reported that he was
unconscious
the next day
Terry goes into the VA emergency room
so what does the defense have to say
about these things
first they say that's not the way this
happened he hid me from behind I know
the witness Ramon says he heard me
scream and look up and saw the crash I
never saw Sanderson before he hit me
Sanderson was the one who hit me
this wasn't my fault
they also say the defense this is all
sanderson's fault he's the one who can't
remember the crash
my ski instructor Eric Christensen said
he saw Sanderson above me making big
turns
and going really fast
this is sanderson's fault
and they say look what's the big deal
he's 69 years old our doctors say he had
some dementia and blindness in an eye
and many other problems yeah you broke
some ribs but those will heal and 85
percent of people with brain injuries
heal
what's the big deal
oh and
and look at his high test scores he
can't have a brain Dem can't have a
brain injury
and finally they say so what if he had a
hinge
head injury and four broken ribs on the
day of the crash
eight hours later he
he wrote to his daughter I'm famous
that shows he can't be injured and this
is just about celebrity of Miss Paltrow
because of the defense's claims
that nothing Miss Paltrow did caused
this crash
and his injuries
we on behalf of Terry and his family we
contacted Dr Richard Bain a neurologist
and biomedical engineer
he applies medicine and physics to
understand traumatic brain injuries like
this
Dr Bain
the defense says nothing they did caused
this crash and Terry sanderson's
injuries is that true Dr Bain says
well I don't know
give me everything you've got including
medical records scans x-rays reports and
so forth and I want to examine him
then I'll look at his case
but just so you know
you may not like what I say
but I'll tell you true
so we give Dr Bain the x-rays to test
the reports
and Terry's season for an exam
and after Dr Bain has reviewed these
things
we call them up
so Dr Bang
what do you think
Bain says
no actually absolutely she caused this
crash she hit him from behind
which means she was higher on the hill
than him
well but how do you know well he broke
his four ribs when she hit his
uh when she hit his back knocking him
down to the ground and she landed on top
of him just like Ramon the witness said
the only way for his broken ribs on the
right side
could fracture like this is if she hit
him from behind and landed on top of him
pressing his right arm into his chest
that's really the only way to have
broken four ribs like this two severely
broken
well Dr Bain the defense says he should
have recovered from the concussion
well that makes no sense
because he still has symptoms more than
18 months after the crash that means his
brain injury is permanent
well Dr Bain will you be willing to come
to court
to testify to our jury
so we can get this right because the
defense says they are going to take this
all the way to trial
I'd love to but I'm busy that week
but I can give you my deposition
so last week the parties took Dr Bain's
deposition
you the jury will hear
will see it this week
and just so you know a deposition is an
out of court sworn testimony where the
lawyers on both sides
testify or ask questions to a witness
and in this case it was recorded
so what happened to Terry
well
the day after the crash he goes to the
VA Hospital
at the VA they x-rays ribs and they say
yes you've got four broken ribs two of
them broken completely
and then a few days later they confirmed
Terry suffered a concussion
in this ski crash
over the next year Terry is
seen by various people at the VA
including speech therapists and other
doctors a psychiatrist
and he's trying to get better Terry
doesn't want to have a brain injury
Terry was a
eye doctor in the Army for three years a
captain
that's why he goes to the VA
but after a year he's still got symptoms
of a of a persistent brain injury
so
um
I refer him to a Dr Elena Fong she's a
neuropsych neuro psychologist in Utah
County
and she treats
thousands of people who suffer brain
injuries that are persistent
and Dr Fong
treated Terry
and from about a year and three months
after the crash to about a year and six
months after the crash
Dr Fong will testify in this case via
video deposition because she had to she
couldn't be here for trial also she has
a conference in the Netherlands because
she treats patients around the world and
is a known
treat her of people with persistent
post-concussive symptoms which is
basically a brain injury
so after this litigation began
after 2019
Terry went to see a neuropsychologist Dr
Wendell Gibby of Utah who was examined
and scanned thousands of patients with
injured brains
a neuroradiologist is a medical doctor
who specializes in
Radiology everything from x-rays to MRIs
to CT scans and his specialty is also in
neuroradiology examining the brain but
he also examined the chest x-rays that
were taken at the VA
and we asked Dr Gibby how bad is it
Dr Gibby says it's bad his brain is
permanently injured he has persistent
post-concussive symptoms although we can
treat him he will certainly have
problems with his brain function the
rest of his life
well Dr Gibby the defense says Terry's
problems are pre-existing and his brain
problems were there before the crash
well that's because that's what they
always say about permanent brain
injuries Terry suffered a significant
concussive brain injury in the ski crash
the injury is permanent in other words
Terry will have problems with his brain
the rest of his life
well uh doctor the defense says he has
pre-existing brain issues such as NPH
when he had the brain scan in 2009 seven
years before the crash
NPH is normal pressure and uh
hydrocephalus
basically it's when your brain has too
much fluid in the canals of the brain or
the ventricles
and it builds up and it presses on your
brain
it may actually make you more
susceptible to problems from a
concussion
but many people go their whole life
without any symptoms
and they never know they have mph unless
they get a brain scan
well the evidence will show that
Terry Sanderson had no symptoms of NPH
prior to the ski crash
Dr Gibby says because Terry was
asymptomatic or had no symptoms
before the crash the brain injury he he
suffered in the ski crash is the cause
of his current problems not mph
well the defense is three medical
doctors
the defense has hired three MDS
and two PhD neurosite companies
neuropsychologists say well the mph is
causing his problems
and Dr Gibby says well I'm not sure what
they're thinking but this ski crash
caused Terry's current problems
further like Dr Bain
Dr Gibby thinks it's highly unlikely
that miss Mr Sanderson
hit Miss Paltrow the way he sustained
the injuries to his ribs
is more likely than not caused by Miss
Paltrow landing on his back when Terry
Sanderson hit the ground from the when
she wrote his back after the ski crash
then we talked to Dr Sam Goldstein a
neuropsychologist who has a clinic in
Salt Lake City
treats patients with brain injuries
he's been treating people like this for
decades
we asked Dr Goldstein what can you say
about Terry's injuries the defense says
it's more likely dementia
or
NPH or other problems
well Dr Goldstein says well
it's it's permanent and significant this
this injury he had
when Ms Paltrow hit him because his
family and friends and the people he
knows
before and after the crash
report that he had
very few problems before the crash but
after the crash he has very significant
problems
because of that we know and because it's
lasted for years more than a year and a
half and now it's been lasted for seven
years we know he has persistent
post-concussive symptoms
Goldstein says yes most people recover
but in a situation like this where Miss
Paltrow denies she caused his injuries
it's like his frustration digs into his
frontal lobes so to speak and his
problems are permanent
yes he can alleviate them with treatment
and medication but he will have problems
all his life
and these problems didn't exist to the
uh
before the crash they came after the
crash
and there is objective data that his
ability to cope with life is diminished
well these doctors Dr Bain Fawn Gibby
and Goldstein you'll hear testimony from
two of them by videotape
um
and most doctors like them
say that the most important some of the
most important pieces of evidence for
understanding brain injuries
are these before and after Witnesses
again these are people who knew Terry
before and after the crash
you the jury will hear testimony from
some of them
like his two daughters
and either today or tomorrow you'll also
hear from
uh
Carlene Davidson the girlfriend Terry
had at the time of the crash they had
been together about a year and a half
and they spent a lot of time together
they miss Davidson spent
maybe three out of four weeks with Terry
Sanderson in Salt Lake City they
traveled the world together Carlene
Davidson knew Terry really well
and uh she'll report on what happened
after Terry or after the crash to Terry
a couple of things I'd like to discuss
with you
the media has not been accurate
no Deer Valley Ski employee
saw the ski crash
now some employees saw
some people saw the crying
referencing out
the state that's not going to come in
okay
some people's uh the Deer Valley
employees
did not ski the see the ski crash the
Deer Valley employees saw some things
before the crash and some things after
the crash
Ramon
is the only eyewitness who actually saw
the crash you're going to hear from him
later today he'll be the first Witness
now after this crash well before this
crash Terry was a Charming outgoing
gregarious person he volunteered for
many things he was a retired eye doctor
he had moved from Southern Idaho to Salt
Lake City about 10 years ago
he was
living a full life traveling the world
doing everything possible to enjoy his
life and guard his health he did not
want a brain injury he did everything
possible he could
to fix his brain injury
but after the crash he's no longer
Charming
the before and after witnesses will
show you this we asked Terry to step out
during this part because I didn't want
to rub his nose in his own problems and
during other parts of testimony from his
daughters and some of the other before
and after Witnesses Terry won't be in
the courtroom
at the at the end of this trial
the evidence will have
clearly and convincingly established
that the value
not the cost but the value of the damage
is done to Terry Sanderson
is three million two hundred and seventy
six thousand dollars
we look forward to showing you all of
the evidence
thank you Mr Bueller
Mr Owens
can we have a five minute break and I do
want to address one thing with the court
okay why don't we take a short recess
between the lawyers opening statements
so thank you
thank you
your honor I just I want to renew the
instruction number 45 for the defense
this court has found that there is
insufficient evidence to assert a hit
and run they didn't use the words hit
and run but they said she bolted and
this jury is under the misimpression
that that that is an issue in this case
it's not an issue that was ruled on
summary judgment All That Remains is a
negligence claim one can't be negligent
for bolting from the scene of an
accident that's an intentional conduct
so I asked for that instruction right
now
your honor
no it's the first witness those are his
exact words
and he's testified that
in front of and it's been provided to
defense counsel before the litigation
during the litigation in a deposition
his deposition lasted six hours and the
defense interrogated him on this and he
never changed his testimony and that's
his testimony
now they can quibble with the testimony
and dispute the testimony but I did not
use the word hit and run
Eric Christensen came up people ask are
you okay
the evidence is
um will show that what I said in the
opening is accurate per the only
eyewitness Craig Ramon
and obviously the concern is is that um
is that it may go is that there may be
an implication that it goes to duty and
as long as you're not making an
implication that she had a duty to do
something different
the the testimony of the witnesses is
what the testimony of the witnesses is
you can ask your questions you can point
things out you can make your arguments
but my ruling on on the instruction 45
will stand
thank you
short five minute break
you want something
okay
you need
to see them
are we ready for the jury
Mr Owens you ready okay
foreign
Mr Owens
members of the jury thank you for being
here
partly against your will
it's a beautiful thing
the law
when people are in
big disputes
our system both our U.S Constitution and
our state constitution
allows these disputes to be done openly
publicly
and by a jury of one's peers
and I think it's a beautiful thing it's
slow a lot of people complain about
lawyers but no one gets hurt
in terms of we don't burn people's
houses down we don't do acts of violence
and oddly enough if a jury if a trial is
done right
even the losing party feels that they
were heard and understood and that
uh they feel some sense of peace
so if you can't tell this is a big deal
to the parties and it's really special
that you were chosen you should feel
complimented and perhaps one day you'll
tell your children and grandchildren I
was selected for a jury
and it was an honor to serve and I
helped my community by trying to figure
out a difficult problem that the parties
have
and so I thank you for that
even in Greece ancient Greece they used
to resolve problems like this big
disputes bring in some criminal some are
civil that essentially means can someone
go to jail for it that's criminal is
someone asking for money that's civil so
this is a civil claim
and they would gather the people and
listen to the dispute so this is a very
historic
tradition
the burden of proof is one of your
statements here from the judge and I
just want to comment on it
burden of proof
is a wing of evidence so I put before
you Lady Justice if you're ever in Salt
Lake go to the Salt Lake and city county
building and look up and it's this
statute although this is not the exact
statue of her but you've seen this
around and I've I've done another one
for you here that I I like to keep in my
office
all right so what's important about this
she's blindfolded
so one of the judge's instructions for
you was no sympathy passion or Prejudice
you're not to reward anyone anything
because you feel sorry for them
this is important because over the next
two weeks we're going to hear a lot
about Terry sanderson's mental and
physical health both before the ski
collision and after the skeet collision
and you're going to feel sorrow for him
but we're not here I can feel sorrow too
but that's not why you're here you're
here to figure out if someone
negligently crashed into someone or
if no one did
and I think the law will permit you to
decide that no one was at fault
unlike a car accident or something a ski
Collision is different
there are inherent risks of skiing
I know when I get on the top of the tram
at snowbird
and it's a Gusty day like today and I
say
if I don't do this right I could kill
myself I mean it's it's a breathtaking
wonderful
exhilarating but also a little dangerous
isn't it that we're strapping on pieces
of wood or fiberglass on our boots and
we're going down a very snowy icy Hill
so
that happens
maybe some of you have been hit I've
been hit
skiing it's disorienting it was unhappy
I was unhappy to say the least
but I did recognize it as an inherent
risk I mean
okay let me let me move on on that
so the blindfold the blindfold is I'm
not going to do this because I feel
sorry for someone
then the scales
Mr Sanderson has brought the claim
as a result he has to tip the scale
okay the tie means plaintiff does not
win
Tai goes to the defendant so they have
to tip
that's who brought the claim
that's the wing and then you see the
sword
now the sword can be I'm Seeking Justice
so I'm proactively fighting it and
sometimes Lady Justice is actually seen
with the shield
let me suggest that that sword is being
used
to defend a meritless claim
a false allegation
really kind of an offensive one
that she somehow
left him an unconscious man and bolted
and and it's it's I can tell you
we believe it to be utter BS argument
you're supposed to present what he's
going to show not not argue it we
believe it to be it's fair it's fair
isn't it
sustained it is bordering on argument
Council thank you thank you
be suing for three million dollars
okay
let's I'll I'll tell you what I'm going
to hit damages later I I want to I want
to hit the merits of the case first
so the burden of proof
I wanted to emphasize
and then
instruction 11 says don't abandon your
common sense
so this can look you're going to hear
from brain experts and a lot of people
to talk about this
but don't abandon your common sense that
that's very important
I also want to just reference to you
that uh
you should pay attention more to the
records before someone's thinking
lawsuit then the records after someone's
thinking lawsuit objection argument your
honor this this is an open statement
argument sustain
you're going to see a lot of Records
about what was going on before
and during
and then after
some of the records before indicate that
Terry Sanders had
brain issues before in fact there was a
prior MRI
now
let me hit the accident because I I
don't I'd be silly to address other
issues let me explain what was happening
and can you find that second picture
Miss Paltrow has sentimental feelings
about skiing her dad who left this life
too early took her skiing as a kid at
Alta
she grew up learning to ski and those
are very sentimental trips in fact after
her dad died in his 50s she didn't ski
for a long time because it was an
emotional thing for her
that is Miss Paltrow that is Gwyneth on
the right that is her son Moses on the
left on the very day of this ski
accident
all right so they're going up and this
was also so it was a Sentimental issue
because she had started getting back
into skiing and she did it because she
wanted her kids to learn like she had
another thing she had a boyfriend at the
time who's now her husband
and he has kids the exact same age as
gwyneth's daughter and son
oddly the daughter is the same age as
the daughter and the son as the son and
this was really their first trip to sort
of have a mixed see if this might work
so uh it was a special time and it was a
lovely day so some ski events we worry
about is the sun in someone's eyes no
one's saying that is it a snowy day no
it's a nice day how about was it slick
run no it was a nice groomed run how
about was it really complex Hill no it
wasn't wasn't the Bunny Hill but
bandana who maybe some of you know I
mean it's it's a green hill
um and so none of those factors kind of
come into play moderately busy
and she's skiing uh again with a group
so her group is she Brad now her husband
who you're going to hear from her
daughter Apple who you're going to hear
from Moses who you're going to hear from
and then some Deer Valley people now
these weren't her people these were Deer
Valley instructors I could have hired
Eric Christiansen that day just as
Gwyneth did
um and uh and then Brad has two kids and
they had ski instructors so that was
their group it was kind of a loose group
uh
but uh nonetheless they went to the top
they met at the top of bandana with the
plan this was about 11
30 11 A.M uh we're gonna go down and
have lunch I think it's the Empire Lodge
if I'm not mistaken okay so we're gonna
all kind of ski down
um
Gwyneth is a conservative skier
she always sees on the far right
so if it's like a highway
fast people go on the left I don't know
if it's the same but
it's far right and then
on a small curves
um
and
she's not she's generally watching her
kids but she's not specifically watching
because they're they have their
instructors
she's skiing
enjoying herself
and she hears
suddenly she sees two skis appear
between her skis
and a man
comes up right behind her now they're
not going fast that's kind of the odd
thing here
he comes up
almost body to body like this
and starts groaning
she doesn't know what's going on what's
going on am I being assaulted
she's moving forward
and then she's like they they're begin
falling to the right
and she's
feeling freaked out I think is a fair
statement
and he hits down
apparently his side and his head and she
is essentially falling on him but keep
in mind his skis
are intertwined now with hers
her first reaction
is get away from this
and so she's pulling trying to get away
what has just happened
now
she only has to think about this for a
few seconds to realize okay I'm not I'm
not being assaulted
but this fellow she had a more colorful
word has just run into me
and she said what are you doing or words
to that effect and he he's like I
words to the effect I didn't see you
and then there's a question well who ran
into who and he says did you or you ran
into me and Gwen it's like no you ran
square right into me
and he said
I'm sorry
he doesn't deny saying I'm sorry he
doesn't remember it but he doesn't
dispute it
now she's still ticked off
fact
much has been said about the so-called
uh only eyewitness so you're going to
hear from them this afternoon I don't
have to give you a commentary on him
but he will say he heard and turned
he heard and turned
that's what the Deer Valley guy says
Eric Christiansen one of the instructors
said he heard and turned
and and then saw
so uh
I'll comment just a minute more on Mr
Ramon in just a minute you'll hear about
him
back to gwyneth's story
she's so she's backed up she's safe
Eric's on the scene he's helping people
get their skis off
and he's trying to figure out what
happened now Eric
backing up they started at the hill this
is at the very beginning of the hill by
the way it's not halfway down it's not
three-fourths down it's the first
quarter down
he's trying to figure out what happened
but he had seen
Gwyneth go down
then Terry who who was cutting across
the the whole thing
if I'm misstating it we're going to have
to we're defer to their testimony when
they testify but I'm trying to give you
a big picture he's he's making a wide uh
much wider turning
and guess what he's blind in one eye
and has decreasing Vision in his left
eye
he has hearing aids
he's had heart stroke
many other medical conditions just weeks
earlier he had told his doctor I'm
feeling
old suddenly
uh and Terry's Story by the way is that
he's he's coming across and he sees a
struggling younger woman as not younger
a young struggling female skier
and he's trying he wants to be really
clear
to stay away from her
so he's he's actually turning his head
to clear the beginner skier
and what happens he comes right upon
Gwyneth he's back turns with his better
eye and suddenly she's there
so the Deer Valley report do you mind
by the way Deer Valley is not a party to
this lawsuit the court dismissed Deer
Valley so gwyneth's not Deer Valley Deer
Valley stands on its own rejection
argument your owner
overruled
Deer Valley stands on its own and uh
I don't know if they're going to serve
like there's some massive cover-up or
what but objection argument
sustained hey uh back one I think James
by the way I think the goal is to give
everyone a little better access with
these little screens but it hasn't
worked out today
so Eric Christiansen remember he hears
and he turns and he goes directly over
there he's there within seconds
and he's he's seen what happened
and what does he say can you blow up the
first half
Chief complaint mail skier
took her out from behind
he's he's putting this together and then
let's do the bottom thing and then we
won't we won't focus on exhibits anymore
really today
on this but
first thing male skier said does that
say said I can't read it
anyone
stated
stated was that she appeared right in
front of him thus admitting that he was
the uphill skier she never saw him
because he came in from behind
that was the evaluation from the Deer
Valley skier
from the Deer Valley instructor
interestingly
Eric's trying to figure out Eric
Christiansen the ski instructor is
trying to figure out all right what's
the first question by the way everyone
okay
everyone okay
now they were both
uh
any Collision you take a body blow it
takes a little while to gather your
senses
recognize okay I'm safe okay
but uh his answer was he was okay
and um
he was on his feet
this took minutes
Gwyneth
uh
was not happy still
Moses who you're going to meet he's now
16 but he was a nine-year-old at the
time
was with his instructors instructors
started to come over Moses came over and
he saw his mom and he was worried he
hadn't seen his mom first of all she's
on the ground and she's yelling
at this guy
um
she might have said something like what
the f word and I think she might have
said the f word we're going to figure
that out
and she's mad and he said I haven't seen
my mom like that and he was sort of
personally a little upset
all right and then uh okay everyone's
okay everyone's okay and Eric
Christiansen the ski instructor said a
ski patrol person who's different than
the instructor a ski patrol person came
by
and said everyone okay
and he said
Mr Sanderson and Craig Ramon who you're
going to meet this afternoon
talk to each other
and said we're okay
and they wait they said we're okay and
the ski patrol left
all right now everyone's okay
and then I think Eric Christiansen
okay
he Gwyneth you can go
join your family by the way your
family's waiting for at the bottom Brad
interestingly had heard it and looked up
and saw his wife on the now wife on the
ground and had come back up and she had
skied down to be with them not to leave
by the way you'll never hear the words
hit and run in this whole trial this was
not a hit and run
that plaintiff even had a ski expert
evaluate it and they said it's not a hit
and run so take take that out of your
mind
all right so uh
all right now what's going on okay
everyone everyone's good to go
everyone went
Terry oh right before he left apparently
Eric Christiansen said your buddy just
took out Gwyneth Paltrow
they didn't even no one knew who she was
by the way she had a helmet and goggles
and everything guess who doesn't doesn't
who denied that
Craig Ramon
they're so full first skier
has a whole different crazy story
uh that objection argument your honor
that is our overruled oh they're not
then hey Rhea served my craziness all
right so uh I'll continue the story
everyone's good to go good good to go
okay then they now hear she's Gwyneth
Paltrow
and uh
they're like okay well let's let's ski
down so they ski down a ways further
and Terry
I shouldn't call him Terry Mr Sanderson
uh
does not feel good
he he feels confused he says
so uh you'll hear them like well let's
let's get a ski patrol person now we had
previously waved one off but now we
we've changed our mind
we need ski Patrol
toboggan person comes named Whitney
uh and she she pulls up and they and the
first thing Whitney says is what
happened
and Mr Sanderson says
I don't know I'm not sure
he did not say
I was just hit
interestingly Craig Ramon the friend
uh did not correct that statement
so Craig Ramon by the way never once
told Eric Christiansen
key hit excuse me she hit him
didn't say one word about it
uh
didn't say we need help
part of this crazy story is he says
Sanderson Mr Sanderson was out cold for
two minutes
unconscious
now do you know how long it is to look
at a person
who might be like dead or dying for two
minutes and not do one thing he didn't
do anything
it's it's not true everyone on the scene
was saying absolutely if he was if he
was out it was for seconds
not two minutes
Christy Anson's gonna just ignore
someone who's out cold
he's saying I'm okay he's on his feet
he's declining Ski Patrol
very different story than someone who's
out cold
I said did you start CPR like where you
check his breathing and stuff no I I
didn't do any of it you'll see there are
a lot of ridiculous things I think about
it the direction you're not on an
argument sustained Gwyneth didn't have a
helmet he says Gwyneth didn't have a
helmet or a face
mask or or a goggles on her she had she
had those things
she doesn't go around skiing she she's
safe conscious and she's probably a
little celebrity conscious about like I
don't I don't do that
so anyway
we'll address that this afternoon more
but let me continue the story so he's on
the toboggan
now these Whitney this toboggan person's
pretty smart she goes hey I want you to
remember
I'm going to tell you a few things and I
want you to remember him
and and they're unique things we'll get
into it later and at the bottom of the
hill she's checking them and he he
remembers all of them in fact he posts
he's a poster
so he posts a very happy smiling picture
of the toboggan person and a very
articulate comment repeating like she
went to Michigan she won the ski thing
very detailed and he posts it
okay well that's that's nice but it's
not something you do if you've just
suffered a major traumatic brain injury
all right so articulate everything
at the bottom he's talking he's
conversing this isn't like garbled
garbled crazy talk where you think head
injury is important
so uh he by the way he takes a picture
so he likes to take pictures and post
things on Facebook and everything of
Ramon and one of the women he was skiing
with and they're all smiles
like like you'd post you wouldn't know
like this is taken by someone who just
suffered a major head Collision or
something
and and uh boom it's posted okay great
this is good because we're getting real
life things from him and his own fingers
in his own head
then he goes to an InstaCare person
the care person says no signs of
confusion
okay that's a big issue right if we're
worrying about
uh
by the way uh there's a nurse on your
panel but I I take it from our experts
that you'll hear that if you hit your
head and you say I have confusion
essentially you are diagnosed I mean you
are a con you have a concussion I mean
so maybe it's more than that I might be
simplifying it and forgive me if I am
because nothing I'm saying is evidence
but I'm trying to give you the story
so the guy there is like okay uh
uh there I can't rule out problems so
you should get a CT
a CT is Imaging of the brain and he ends
up going to the VA Hospital the next day
uh the the CT it's interesting so he had
this he had a stroke-like event and lost
his right eye
uh
like six years earlier so we have
Imaging of his brain six years earlier
and guess what
there are defects in that new CT but
guess what they were there before
they were there before and guess what
their experts didn't do
go back and look
to see if the problems in his current
Imaging is present
on his six-year-old CT of the brain
it's kind of crazy they're they're
interviewing him
he's telling them things
but no one's actually trying to go back
and sort of say look is his brain is his
brain different
okay
you're going to hear from some daughters
by the way there was a reference to two
daughters he has three daughters
he's on the outs with that daughter
she paints a not that great story
about
him
before the ski accident
why do we dig into this no one wants to
dig into this
but if a 75 year old man says I don't
think as well as I used to my brain
doesn't work as well as I used to I
forget things
we have to which is why we're all here
we have to go back and look at these
things if he says my relationships were
harmed by Gwyneth
we have to go back
it's kind of a deep dive and say what
were your relationships like before this
and it's not pleasant I mean like half
of the trial is going to be on this kind
of stuff because if someone says I have
a severe three million dollar brain
injury caused by you
we have no
I have a law your lawyer obligation to
represent my client and say what's true
and I'm telling you
he does have confusion he does have
strained relationships he does forget
some things but
guess what it's it's a normal aging
and his pre-existing problems
coming forward and progressing
back to the story so I InstaCare they
say go get a CT uh
tomorrow
and then he posts and let's put that up
so he's a poster okay big on Facebook so
there are lots of pictures of him which
helps us it helps us understand him
what does he post to his daughters
I'm famous
he doesn't post I'm hurt
he doesn't post googly goth is that the
right word
confusing stuff
could you highlight the bottom half
I'm famous
this is a eight
eight pm the accident had occurred just
before lunch
so eight hours later he's home
and then he said here's what happened
from my friend and eyewitness this Craig
and he posts it
he posts it
when wouldn't you be interested to know
what this post was
in real time this video or photo is
apparently video projection argument
your honor that's that's just
that's just trying to explain the
evidence here so you've got evidence uh
I mean this is evidence that will come
in
then it's not there okay
overruled as to that wouldn't we all
like to know
I apologize were it okay yes
wouldn't we like to know what this was
injection argument your honor sustained
it's nowhere to be found
we're in a courtroom seven years later
trying to figure out what happened it
was right there
nowhere to be found and then can you do
the top half
this is his daughter
I can't believe this is all on GoPro
where's the GoPro do we want it we want
it
it's nowhere to be found
I'm glad you're okay
he's telling his daughters I'm okay
all right
we're trying to put together a lot of
facts you're gonna hear I don't like 20
people are going to come in
half of them medical people and try to
figure this out
it'll be interesting I I think after
this trial ago that was cool actually
you learned a lot and you you are given
to our community but about half of the
information you're going to hear if you
find that Gwyneth did not cause the
accident
you could actually can disregard
all the damages talk
so we're going to hear a week of
evidence on Terry's brain Sam Mr
sanderson's brain
but
if you find no negligence by Miss
Paltrow
then
you can disregard all that your honor
object this is this is a classic
argument
sustained
one dollar bill
Gwyneth
was hurt by Mr sanderson's negligence
when he came up behind her
paralleled her
and went she says her she has a knee she
has a prior knee problem she was worried
about it
separated from him with help
then boyfriend came up
and she is upset
she has a
anyone sustaining a blow is is upset
she's sore
she never went to a doctor but for this
by the way
but
she was it rattled her and it physically
hurt her
when they were dismissed they went down
to the bottom of the hill
and who was waiting for her daughter
Apple
now 18 then
eight I think
no no no 11. sorry I got that mixed up
so
and Apple's like what took you so long
and she said
some a-hole
just ran into me
I think she used the real word
all right why is this important
she didn't say
I just ran into someone
she was mad and over lunch she was mad
and then after lunch she said
that guy kind of hurt me
and I'm not going to ski the rest of the
day
there's even a text from glenna's on
phone
to
Eric Christianson
and they're like Moses wants to know if
you're coming
I'm going to go in that guy kind of hurt
me
and she went in and she lost her full
day pass that she had paid for and she
only got a ski half a day
in addition
she had paid for her instructor
who now was diverted from teaching her
son Moses
to take care of of this Collision issue
and so
we ask you for a dollar now this is a
lot to go through for a dollar
but it's an actual dollar
because she
she had come with her family to enjoy a
family vacation this should get an
argument that's just classic argument
these are facts
overruled as to the comments that are
being made right now those are facts
yeah and let's keep the interruptions to
a minimum would we well Council go ahead
I mean the the objections have been
valid some of them
so uh
she came for a family vacation half the
afternoon
was kind of ruined
and so that dollar is important to us
it's important to my client
let me hit a few other things you've
been very patient
I think I said it's hard to unpack
someone a 75 year old who says I don't
think as well as I used to
Heaven Help me if my daughters were
called to the stand
and they say hey let's talk about all
your dad's mental quirks and problems
and his physical health and his
deterioration as he ages
I I wouldn't want to be present for that
uh it would be hard
and yet we're here because Mr Sanderson
is making that that allegation and so
we have to do it so I don't want to look
like I'm beating up on an on a kindly
old man
but keep in mind we have to do this
because they have said
Gwyneth owes me three million dollars I
mean we have to address that
so I kind of apologize in advance
Mr Sanderson threw a press conference
and he said Gwyneth objection honor this
is this is irrelevant this is factual
argument this is factual sustained there
hasn't been
would you please approach
Sanderson said
three years later she she came out of
the Jungle like King Kong
screaming
when asked
in real time
by Gwyneth
he said I apologize I'm sorry
when asked by the ski instructor
he said she appeared right in front of
me
and when asked by the toboggan person he
said
I don't remember
I don't know
or I'm not sure
Mr Sanderson said
his memories of this case
get better over the years
that's all I'm going to say about that
that's not how memory works
one more comment on damages
plaintiffs
he was a vet we we salute him for that
he went to the VA
and he went at one month
he went at one year
I guess one year and two months and one
year at three months okay so three
different assessments neuropsych
assessments this is where a smart person
is trying to figure out and he is saying
I'm more confused since the ski accident
and they're doing testing on them these
are not hired
experts like many of the people you're
going to hear
these are as VA people
and he's complaining and they're doing
assessments on them
and what does he do
above average above average above
average above average above average
a year and two months
high IQ
High verbal comprehension
High perceptive reasoning working memory
is average processing speed average
overall cognitive ability intact
one year and three months later goes to
someone else
these are three different people
three different people
he's alert
his affect is appropriate his speech is
normal his thought process is logical
linear and goal oriented all good his
perception no disturbance attention
concentration within normal limits
recent memory within normal limits
remote memory within normal limits
all normal or above normal
I
these are the not the hired people let
me just say that
back to Lady Lady uh
Justice please I am finishing up
plaintiff said
if these are my notes in his opening
she was dangerous and Reckless
with her nine-year-old son who's a
beginner
so you know
dangerous and Reckless you you decide we
need your help the community
this is argument again sustained thank
you
watch me ski there was a comment somehow
she was distracted
uh
Gwyneth doesn't remember that the kids
don't remember that but if
if I guess someone says hey look at me
look at me but these these aren't like
three-year-olds at a swimming pool
she she is focused she is not distracted
she got
taken out from behind
I mean that's what happened
and uh
that's enough on that
his posts so again
we can curse
Public Media or social media but it does
do one thing well doesn't it it's like
sort of documents people
and he's a poster so guess what
he went on
traveling all over the world
after this
like 10 trips
all over the world
and we'll talk about that I'm not even
talking about the domestic trips which
he did those too but I'm talking about
big long International trips
he does yoga he swims he stays fit his
life is not a disaster there's an
argument again overruled
our experts you will hear from them and
I won't go through Name by name
two are East fold and ask a Nazi
these are smart people who are trying to
put everything together
and are just saying
so
he's aging
he has prior problems
and he's now obsessed
essentially with this lawsuit
I mean I think the best thing
after this is over this will be a good
thing win or lose I think contraction
your honor that's an argument sustained
they will say that our expert Jackson
your honor
our experts will say that is that
objectionable no
you've been very kind I'm going to end
here with uh
Lady Justice
so the blindfold you get we're not going
to feel sorry for them we're not going
to
make our decision on that the weighing
of evidence
they have to they have to have more
evidence than not
and the sword we are defending a false
allegation and we need your help and
thank you so much for doing it
I'm done and uh
overall just as a little latitude there
that's about 10 overruled objections
during my closing which uh I think is
inappropriate your honor
why don't we approach the bench please
okay we're going to take our noon recess
at this time I've been informed that
lunch will be available for the jurors
just to let you know the parties have
agreed to split the cost of lunches so
that you don't have to try to travel out
to go find lunch you're certainly
welcome to go if you'd like but lunch
will be provided for you and we'll
reconvene at 1 pm thank you
anything for the for the court
Council okay we'll see you at 1pm thank
you
are you ready for the jury Council
okay
okay we're ready
good
foreign
thank you
okay good afternoon everyone
we're ready for our first witness Mr
Sykes and who would that be
Craig Ramon
Mr Ramon if you could come forward
please
and walk right over here sir and be
sworn in as a witness
I'm here hi do you swear that the
testimony you were about to give in the
case now before the court will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you God
and then right around over here sir
I kind of adjust that to get comfortable
okay
uh please State your full name and your
home address hi Craig James
Ramon and uh how old are you sir
um 58 okay
uh where did you go to High School uh
Cottonwood High School that's in Salt
Lake City or Salt Lake County Salt Lake
okay and tell us about your work
background
well when I was 18 I went to work for a
glass company called National
Natco glass worked there for about a
year and a half
and then from there I quit
and then I went to work at Central Glass
and uh for about a year and a half
that's in Salt Lake City yes downtown
okay
and then from there I started my own
glass company
what was it called uh Craig's glass okay
and I and I started that about 20 21
years old
and then I um I bought some commercial
property when I was about 24.
and I built a commercial building
and uh then when I moved into the
commercial building I ended up
uh changed the name to A1 National glass
about what year was that roughly
approximately
87 okay and
um we the owner sole owner yes okay
yeah and uh just so the jury understands
the basic background what what kind of
glass did A1 do auto glass so Auto Glass
that was their specialty yes okay okay
um
and how long did you work with A1
87 until about what year uh 2013. okay
what happened then
um I basically sold out and retired
okay and so you when you sold out and
retired you were 50
um that's 48 48 okay uh do you need to
work now no so so you don't work now no
okay
um
what do you do now during this during
the uh the winner in the winter in the
winter time I like to see okay and then
in the summertime I like to travel and
scuba dive
uh travel and scuba dive yes okay
now and skiing just so they get an idea
of your your ski ability
um What's um
what what year did you start ski I
started when I was what age I should say
I started when I was about five years
old okay
and uh by the time you you finished high
school what level were you
um an expert I actually at skiing yeah
um I was an expert I actually competed
in freestyle freestyle yeah was your
objective to go to the Olympics at some
point yeah the Olympics were starting to
come around at that time and and I
wanted to shoot for the Olympics okay
but that never happened all right
so some may be scared some not there's
beginner obviously
intermediate would be number two
Advanced yes an expert yes and you're in
the expert yes okay
um
roughly in the last say four or five
years
how many days did you ski per year
during those years
uh the the most I've skied was it was
154.
and in one year one one skis season and
this this year I'm I'm about 70. okay
and there's still snow up there right
okay there's a lot of snow all right uh
now uh travel tell the jury
some of the places you've traveled
uh South South Africa Papua New Guinea
uh Sydney Australia
um Bangkok
um Phuket Thailand Maldives and Indian
Ocean Palau
Galapagos Islands
keto Ecuador the Amazon rainforest
Costa Rica Cocos Islands the
Cancun Cozumel Bahamas
making me jealous now
okay so quite a few places yes and how
many
how often have you been scuba diving on
those trips
most of them are scuba diving and uh
okay yeah
but what I like to do is I a lot of
times I like to go to
speckled some some background is
appropriate thank you
okay I'm sorry I didn't mean to
interrupt you and so could you repeat
that you know I
let's see
so it was a lot of times what I like to
do is like for instance uh I went to
Bangkok and then and then from there I
went over to Phuket to scuba dive okay
so they're both in so sometimes you
would combine an overseas trip with a
scooping yeah the only time I ever went
on a trip wasn't for associated with
with scuba diving with South Africa and
that was an African safari uh tell the
jury if you would how you know Terry
sings
um
my girlfriend at the time uh well Terry
Sanderson he started a Meetup group at
adalta and so stop a second let me do
something don't know what I'm here okay
meetup group it's it's it's uh
a meetup group it's meetup.com and you
can somebody can like for instance Terry
he he
started a a group there and then you can
sign up
for this group anybody can sign up for
for say skiing or Pottery or hiking and
then if somebody wants to make it make a
go skiing one day they'll say for
instance
we're going to be at Alta at nine
o'clock at this lift and then anybody
can go and so anybody can can go there's
there's been people from out of the out
of the out of the state that will be in
town for the weekend and they'll
actually go and and uh and go to these
meetup groups so was this ski meetup
group one that Terry started years okay
uh how many times did you see
with Terry before the ski crash which is
February 26 26
um about six
six times yes
uh how would you
excuse me
uh characterize him in terms of
friendship
he's an acquaintance okay
is he a good friend no no okay do you do
a lot of things with him
uh
for the the day of the ski crash
um
had you done anything with him other
than six meetup groups you know okay
now
um
I assume that you saw him skiing on each
of those prior times right yes tell the
jury what kind of sheer Terry Sanderson
was
um he was an advanced expert I'd say
he's
Advanced expert he he he'd skied one run
with me the uh that it was an expert run
we were with a
in a meetup group and there was one guy
that was really good skier we broke away
from from the group because they were
going to go to lunch and we went up by
the Supreme Limited at Alta and this you
know this this guy wanted to go down
this really steep run and it was a
really narrow and and there's trees on
both sides and it's really narrow and
Steep and long and this guy wanted to go
down so he went down and then I was
right behind him and I went down and
then Terry was right behind me and then
we skied down to the bottom and he cut
the guy that went down first got you
know he stopped and then I was right
behind him and Terry is right behind me
I didn't see him skiing but he was on my
Tails all right and so uh
maybe some nonski or sure like I said uh
typically how do beginners ski
um they skied well that snow plow and
then they'll go go back and forth across
the ski run kind of the whole run
sometimes right yeah okay yes did Terry
do any of that when he's watching no
uh have you ever seen Terry aside from
the day of the crash collide with anyone
no have you ever seen him bump into
anything like at lunch or something like
that no
did you ever hear him complain he can't
see no
uh
okay now uh
did you ever ski with Terry after
the ski Collision of February 26th yes
the I skated with him uh two times the
next ski
so that would be the the 16-17 ski
season then right yes December to April
let's say yeah all right okay uh tell
the jury how has he been
he he was having a hard time he just uh
he was snow plowing and he wouldn't uh
he his he went up was kind of skiing
with a girl named Robin and she was a
pretty good skier and and he was
snowplowing having a hard time getting
down down the hill and and he kept
asking me and and and and Robin
um you know what am I doing wrong what
am I doing wrong and he just you know he
says in my plant my pool is right and
and you know and he he just he just
didn't didn't have it and he just uh he
he didn't have it at all and he just was
he wasn't the same Siri as he as he was
the uh previous year okay
do you know what the rules rules of the
road are for skiing yeah the the first
thing is seeing under control
I'm talking about just as a as a skier
yeah just just a second I'm going to
overrule it as to this witness's
personal knowledge as a skier and not as
an expert in the rules of the road for
skiing okay
control
yes okay what's another rule of the road
uh you you the downhill skier has the
right-of-way that sometimes said yield
to the downhill skier uh yield yes okay
because downhill skiers don't have eyes
in the back of their head no can't see
you come no okay what's another rule of
the road uh you never leave an accident
you know if there's a two people are you
know Collide you never you never leave
you wait until you make sure everybody's
okay and then you you actually
give give in contact information to each
other
exchange information yes let's uh let's
go for but I apologize for my coffin
getting over cold I think so anyway
um
Let's uh dive into
the bandana run
on February 26 2016. okay
do you have a good memory of that day
yes okay and uh in your Meetup group
that day
how many were there roughly six okay
and uh
who was your ski companion that day
pardon me who was your ski companion
that day uh Joanne okay
and did you when you rode up the list
did you ride together or separately
um we usually wrote together but
sometimes certainly because there was
the the lifts they they carry four
people and we had six people okay uh
describe for the jury the kind of day it
was please uh it was a sunny day
is it Friday wasn't it yes and uh
how was the traffic
there was quite a few people it was a
busy day okay
uh
did he go in the same chair
or can you remember if you want the same
chair with Terry before the bandana run
um I don't remember if I went in the
same chair okay that day
was there anything
excuse me Terry showed you or
demonstrated that showed that he was
impaired in any way that day no okay uh
was he bumping into anything no was he
falling over no
any other ski problem was that day no
no
um
to the point where there was a collision
how far down from the top of the lift
were you
roughly whether the Collision happened
probably I'm guessing maybe two 300
yards down from the top of the lift okay
and how far away were you when you
noticed there was a collision from
probably about 35 40 feet well just to
show
instruction
what do you call this the
same measure measure tape measure there
you go I'm going to let you hold this
and I want you to tell the jury when I
get out here
how far away
this door is back here
that's 43 feet
[Music]
the record reflect that I was at the
inner door not the outer door
okay and he measured we're measuring
from the witness chair
now
Mr Ramon
you see where I was standing with that
door back there yes and you had the end
that showed the measurement right yes 43
feet yes okay
tell the jury if that's about the
distance it was a way from the point of
impact
yeah so that's about right
uh
time that you saw Terry that day was he
doing anything other than parallel skein
no all right
tell the jury if you would
what you saw and heard that day
at approximately 11 45 a.m on February
26th
2016. tell him what you saw well we were
skiing down
down the bend the down the run and then
and then I heard this this this BL this
this scream and then I looked over and
then about you know maybe one or two
seconds
um and then I hear the scream and then
and then and then I see this this this
skier just slam into the back Terry and
then when she just slammed him how hard
very hard I mean very hard and so Terry
she hits him right directly in the bag
and so then uh then his skis are like
even in your skin your skin like this
because skis his skis actually the tips
go out like this and he falls face down
so he's kind of he's kind of spread
eagle and he goes face down and
gwyneth's on the top of him and they go
down like this and then Gwen hits him
and then bounces off and slides to the
right about five or ten feet
now at the time he didn't know it was
Gwyneth did you no turn that out later
yes so the skier that hit him from
behind hit him hard yes and Terry goes
down does he stop abruptly yes okay and
how loud was the screen it was it was
loud
how much time will last between the time
you heard the scream and saw the
Collision uh about a second or two
now
uh I'd like to ask you
uh tell the jury
and by the way describe excuse me
describe
uh what happened to the two bodies after
you saw the Collision briefly
so so the tooth so the two bodies so so
Terry stops and then Gwyneth kind of
slides down I'm about five or ten or the
spider one no she bounced off the top of
him and then she she slid down to the to
the right side and she slid down
um about five or ten feet and so so she
so here's basically Daniel Terry's here
and gwenis right here
what did you do I just I squeaked the
skied down and then I went on to to the
left side
um of Terry and you uphill or downhill
from Terry
I was up field I was I was down I was I
was uphill but then when I stopped I was
downhill
um I was about I was uh
I was about equal with Gwyneth and so so
Terry was when when Terry went down
gwena slid to the to the down the five
and five or ten feet and I came to the
other side and then I skied down about
and I was about down about five or ten
feet and so Gwyneth and I were basically
when she got up we were facing each
other how far away
um I would I would probably say
maybe 10 feet okay now uh how long did
it take you to get over there to that
scene oh just a second or two
okay all right and uh aside from
Gwyneth we now know it was going I
didn't know at the time and Terry
was there anybody else at the scene when
you arrived anybody else at all no okay
huh
what did you do when you got to the
scene tell the jury
well I wouldn't like when I got there I
just was asking Terry are you okay are
you okay and uh and and Terry he wasn't
he wasn't moving his his face was
actually in the snow and and his his
arms are out like this and I mean his
his helmet's stuck kind of in the snow
and so I'm asking him and then and then
gweneth gets up and then I'm asking her
are you okay and uh
and
and uh and then and then from there
um
let me stop it there for a second from
there
at that time did Gwyneth Paltrow we now
know it was her say anything at all
utter any words at all to you no I asked
her if she was okay and she just looked
at me and then I asked her again she's
standing up or down on the ground uh she
was she was standing up she got up
pretty quick
uh did she talk to anyone else
no came over no the entire time she was
there four minutes or so whatever it was
never settled did she say anything any
words come out of her mouth no no
uh
what did Terry say anything
uh he wasn't talking I mean he just he
was he he didn't even start moving for
for probably a couple of minutes was he
was he unresponsive or was it responsive
no he was on
unresponsive okay now a few seconds
after you got there that someone else
arrived and who
yeah
um it's Eric he he showed up Eric
Christensen yes spelled Christian but he
says Christensen right uh I'm not sure I
don't know okay now did Mr Christensen
ever introduce himself to you no
you didn't know his name no tell the
jury how he was dressed
he he had a green Deer Valley coat on so
he was an employee
uh tell the jury then what happened over
the next 30 to 45 seconds tell the jury
well he he came up and he came up to the
left of me and and then and then he
starts yelling at Terry and he's like
what'd you do what did you do and
Terry's not moving he's just not he's
not moving his face his face down and he
keeps saying what did you do and so and
so it got and he was yelling when he
came down but then it just kept getting
worse and worse kept getting getting
higher and higher and it's like what did
you do and so so I just I I was getting
before you go any further okay describe
for the jury the level of hostility that
you observed from a green jacketed
Eric Christensen tore Terry on the
ground he was very hostile
describe it but he was just yelling and
he and he just and he was yelling to the
point where I was thinking I didn't say
anything but I was thinking to myself
man you need some mellow out here and
and so I I got to the point where I was
I was tired of it I was concerned about
Terry Terry's not moving and so then I
ended up I was he was down a little bit
a little bit lower than I was so I just
moved a few feet in front of him so he
was looking you just would be yelling
right at me and then when I did that he
stopped yelling at him the the level of
hostility concern you as a person yes
well Terry was out I mean he was you
know and and I was concerned about you
know Terry was you know what was wrong
with Terry and and I just was I didn't
know how bad he was her I didn't and and
when when he when he was yelling I was
just I just it just it just it just made
me just I didn't I didn't know what to
think I didn't know you know just the
the way he was yelling at that but I was
very concerned about Terry but when you
see in between them and he calmed down
yeah he stopped talking
Alice Christensen said uh in that
sequence
stained
um
did you did you at some point did you
kind of did you learn the name of this
fear that hit Terry
uh yes okay uh and how did you learn
that name
well well she she ended up taking off
and going down and then she came she
went down and then
from where she was standing she probably
went down about 15 20 feet okay and uh
stopped and she came around and stopped
and then and then that Eric said uh
Gwyneth uh Paul just took took out your
buddy
and uh I'm sorry you said what he said
Gwyneth Paltrow just took out your your
buddy
oh your buddy took out Gwyneth Paltrow
no
um what what did Christians say
what's the question yeah yeah and I'm
talking about a rest just eye event here
uh uh what did you hear
at that scene at that time in this
excited condition what did you hear from
whom
well well he he told me that Gwyneth
Paltz Gwyneth Paltz wrote Let's Race
chest I judge so it's overruled thank
you yeah he
um Eric told me that Gwyneth Paltrow
took out uh Terry
was he accusing Terry of taking out
Gwyneth Paltrow too no okay all right uh
did the
uh
uh at this time and before
Miss Paltrow left the scene okay
the chi offer her name no okay did she
offer any contact information no
did she offer any identifying
information no
did she ask if Terry was okay no
but she asked if Terry was hurt no but
she asked if anyone needed any kind of
help no
that she asked if she could leave the
scene no
okay
no
you said she she skied down a little bit
uh tell the jury what happened then
after she screwed down uh the hill 20
feet or so like you said what happened
then
yes yes so that that's
that uh was so she so she stopped and
then then and then that's that's when I
backed up
and uh well I backed up
and that's when I backed up and then was
gonna go down and you know and check on
her and then then she just bolts and
just takes off
she just went straight down and then
there was a there was just went straight
down and there was a guy and and a kid
that was I believe was with with uh with
Gwyneth and they actually stopped about
20 25 feet above us
um on on Terry's right side so so
they're basically above
above Gwen about 20.5 feet
and so then so she takes off and then
and then the kid actually comes down and
then he goes on the right side of Terry
and then the the the the the the the the
guy he came on the left side of Terry
and he see right next to me and he's
looking me just goes real slow and he's
looking at me and look at me and the
other doll for the kid the adult the
adult comes by and gives me and just has
given me this really dirty look
and I was like I don't know why you give
me a dirty look I just and he just
slowly just skied behind me and then
they both took off right after after
Gwyneth did the mountain host
Mr Christensen ever tell you that he saw
what happened he saw the impact do you
ever tell you that no I I asked him that
uh no he did not let me show you exhibit
three
before you put that I was there an
agreement to admit exhibit three
let's get it out
I mean you can hand it to the witness
but not show it to the jury until it
gets admitted okay
this is the one showed to the jury
during opening statement by Mr Collins
that's if that was the one it's the one
you showed during opening statement Mr
Owens
the report sure of course okay is that
defense exhibit three Mr Sykes I believe
so okay defense exhibit three is
received well it's planners exhibitory
plaintiff's exhibit three you might have
a different number but it's the same as
the same exactly
okay now I don't know
can I have my pointer
I use my pen as a pointer uh
I don't know if you can read this
uh it's a little hard to read you want
to step down here and take a look at it
do you mind if I bend this forward
stand up for there
see that date over there 226 yes
is that about the right time
uh yeah
yes yes
describe how the action occurred
you read that
or do I record it yeah just can you can
you read the can you read it for me okay
that should work
okay
I didn't see it can you hear him
did he tell you orally
that he didn't see it too
yes okay
now
look at this
I'll ask you
I'm going to read this too because it's
kind of hard to read
under additional Congress first thing
males male
uh she stated
was that she appeared
uh
I can't
she appeared
anybody read that no word here
right there you go
you're right
okay I'll be there again
okay
first thing
male ski stated was that she appeared
right in front of her
now stop right there for a minute
the male skier
is Terry Sanderson
right okay okay yeah that's no scary yes
did you ever hear
so I think I think this has been misread
if if we're going to read it let's read
it correctly well I think I think you
can bring that out in cross-examination
go ahead Mr Sykes I'll read it again
first thing male skier stated was that
she appeared right in front of him
okay
I think I'm reading that correctly
question for you Mr Ramon
did the male skier
I.E Terry Sanderson ever say anything
like his reporter care no okay and then
he says thus admitting that he was the
uphill skier
see that
Terry Sanders never say he was the
uphill steer no he did not he never said
that
who was the uphill spear from what you
saw
at Gwyneth was
okay
is that an accurate statement
she no no The credibility of the
statement
I think it's okay as a preface in his
question
no
uh
um
some have claimed
that Miss Paltrow
was at the scene for eight minutes what
is your recollection of how long she was
there she was there for probably three
or four minutes okay
how long was the mountain host there
uh probably about seven eight minutes
okay now let me ask you about Mr
Christensen
and ask
thank you if any of these things
happened
did Mr Christensen
ever ask either you or Terry your names
no
did he offer any contact information for
Gwyneth Paltrow no
did he ask for your contact information
no
he asked if Terry Sanderson was okay
no did he ask if Terry Sanderson was
hurt
no
you ask if anybody needed help no
that he'd offer assistance no
the offer
to call Ski Patrol
okay
let me ask you
did he ask
Ed if it was okay for Miss Paltrow to
leave the scene without giving her
contact information no
no
there was a mention in the opening
statement you weren't in the courtroom
when I represent to you that to Mr Owens
said that another Deer Valley person
came by during the whole sequence
now did you did another dear family
person come by while you were there no I
never saw him okay now what happened
after the screaming was over what what
what did people do well not miss Paltrow
but Christensen and Terry
well so Terry finally started to move
and then his skis his he's are out like
this and his face is down and so he he
needed to kind of
get his skis back and so he ended up
lifting his right ski up I believe and
then moving it to the other side so his
so his skis would be parallel and and
and if if I would have been thinking
straight I would have taken his skis off
for him but but I I didn't and I just
wasn't thinking I was just wasn't
thinking and so then so then he gets his
ski so his head's his face downhill but
his skis are still up or his face is
downhill and his skis are uphill and so
then he slowly is just trying to to move
around and get his skis so they're
downhill so that that way you know he
can he can get a
okay now uh
did Terry Sanderson was he described for
the jury at this point in time
when you're
what what you've just described describe
Terry's mentation describe and that's a
bad word describe Terry's
a conduct in speech
well when he finally started to kind of
move around a little bit he was still
out of it and he and he he started to
come the first thing he started to talk
about was he just just says my ribs he
just he was just complaining about his
ribs
and that's that's that's pretty much all
he was saying was he able to have
a conversation really no he he couldn't
even talk did he apologize to miss
Paltrow like has been represented no
okay
I did uh Terry Sanderson tell Eric
Christensen that he Terry Sanderson was
okay
to say he was okay Terry Sanderson never
said anything
uh
what other things can you describe about
Terry's condition at that moment uh
during that sequence anything else he
just looked just totally out of it he
just looked like phased uh he just he
looked like he was in a lot of pain was
he making any sense no no
how about his mental status mental
acuity
he was he was just out of it he he was
just out of it
now at some point
did Mr Christensen leave the scene yes
okay
uh now what tell a jury excuse me what
happened there Mr christensen's gone he
skis off what happens then
well well uh
before before he before he left Eric
pulled poll Terry up and then once Terry
was on his on his feet
he he went
Terry skis were downhill and so he he
went and he put his skis next to Terry's
and so he his skis couldn't slide and
then he grabbed his hand and yanked him
up and then once he was on his feet then
Eric just took off he bowled into did Mr
Christensen do anything to make sure
there wasn't a back injury or a neck
injury before he grabbed his hands and
pulled him up no
okay so you're standing there on the
hill
bandana
alone
with Terry Sanderson correct yes tell
the jury what happened then well so
we're standing there and I'm talking to
Terry and he's he's still not he's still
out of it and I'm you know and I'm at
that point I stopped asking if he's okay
because he just wasn't okay and so then
I figured you know just just let's just
get down the hill I didn't say that to
him I'm just thinking it's an easy run
let's just get down to the bottom of the
hill and we'll do it for then
and uh and so then so then we start
going down down the hill and he's really
having a hard time going going down the
hill and I mean he's snowplowing and
he's bend over and you know he looks
like he's in a lot of pain and uh and he
you know he's just bend over with his
nice snow plowing and and so we get down
and I'm talking to Terry and I'm like
are you okay you know and and he's
saying nothing so we go around this Bend
and then I'm like Terry let's stop so so
hands are pulling over to to the right
side and then I came came uh next to him
and I was I was like
Terry
um I didn't say Terry as I said
do you know your name
and he's and he goes
Terry
and I'm like
this isn't good
I try to say four or five seconds
and so and so then
I said do you know where you are
and he just shook his head and just like
no
and so then at that at that point we
were on the right side of the Run
Deer Valley employee the same color red
red or green
um code it was on the other side and so
I waved waved my ski pool and the guy
came over and and I told him I said I
asked him do you have a cell phone
and I said because because this he's got
a head injury does that work yes why
he just was was out of it and he just
didn't know his name didn't know where
he was at
you know he said they're down no
continue
and so so then he
he
um gets on on on the phone or radio or
whatever he had and then he calls the
ski patrol and then the ski patrol comes
down the ski patrol came pretty quick
they were there within probably a couple
minutes
so so describe how they arrived and who
was there and what they look like
uh the the it was just the ski just one
skate Patrol came down
and it was it was a female
and she brought a toboggan down it's
aboggan yes okay now I assume most
people know what that is but just in
case describe it what's the debugging uh
toboggan it's like a sled and they they
it's it's just a sled that they that
people can get in and then they have
handles where where somebody can that's
hurt and land you know and then then
Escape is Rule can take him down to the
bottom
okay
his name was Whitney Smith do you know
that one way or the other I I heard that
later later okay Whitney Smith hey now
describe
Terry's emotional state
at this point when she shows up and
talks to him for a few minutes what did
he look like what did he appear to be
like well he he looked like he was in in
the days and he looked fearful and then
when this when the ski boots or when the
ski patrol came
it really made him really frightened him
and uh and I think I think because he
didn't know what was going on and then
all of a sudden this Escapist roll comes
down with the toboggan and and uh he
he's just he's just frightened your
honor there's there's several
speculation comments there where Terry's
going to testify himself
yeah just a second
um as to relevance or firsthand
knowledge it's overruled
no child like an adult or what what do
you what do you look like yeah and so so
he just looks pride and so this the
skiba throw came up and so so three of
us it was me tearing the skiba's rule
and the the um ski patrols trying to
talk to Terry and I'm trying to talk to
the skebitz rule and Terry's looking at
me like a like a like a small child
that's just just frightened and and he's
looking at me like
like help me help me and uh and I just
at that point the the the the the the
the ski patrol knew he had a head injury
and so I I just I just figured you know
what I just got to get away from here
and so so at that point I ended up going
up the the next to the the the Deer
Valley employee because the Deer Valley
employee was waving people off because
we came around this Bend
and so I went up and it was right next
to next to the employee and so we were
there was two of us that were kind of
blocking skiers from coming around
and then and then so so so she so she
gets Terry into the wagon
and uh and then takes takes Terry down
okay now
um
uh skip ahead he did you see behind them
or what did you do
well um after the ski patrol came I
ended up calling Colin Kurt and he's the
the guy who was in charge of this meetup
group and I told him what had happened
and so because they were they were down
already so they got and went and jumped
and got on the ski lift and went up
and so so they when
when they they
um when the when the skivot rule went
down and then the mountain hosts he
thanked me says you know thanks
and he went down and and I saw
um Terry's friend come flying by me and
and so I knew that I knew that Joanne
would be right behind because Joanne's
not that fast of a skier and so I just
waited
and so I waited for her
and then she came down and I explained
to her what had happened and then after
that we slowly skied down to the to the
bottom of the hill
the First Stage Station yes okay tell
the jury what happened at the first aid
station at uh the Empire Lodge at Deer
Valley that day yes we so we ended up
getting going down there and uh and
everybody was down there
and Terry was talking to to a nurse I
believe it was a nurse
and when we so we we
um so we Joanna and I just kind of stood
there and then and then uh Kurt he
wanted me to go go up the hill with him
and go skiing I just didn't really want
to go
and so then so then uh
um about a half an hour 20 to 30 minutes
went by and there was really nothing I
can do and uh you know the Terry was
talking to the nurse and and whatnot and
so I actually ended up going up and did
a couple runs with Kurt and the other
guy that was in the group and then I
came back down to check on Terry and
then Kurt or Kurt and the other guy
ended up going back up and going skiing
uh and she didn't want to get in the way
um
tell the jury their observations of
Terry's condition
before you left he was he still wasn't
coherent
he uh and uh he was when I I when I left
he was pretty much still just talking to
the they were just checking Terry out
and evaluating him yeah did you hear the
word concussion mentioned
um later on the the nurse told me they
thought that I was going to be too
in your opinion what was he making any
pain complaints and if so describe those
to the jury yes he was uh yeah he was
still complaining about his ribs okay
multiple times oh yeah he yeah he was
from basically from the very beginning
was he fully coherent no okay
what were the plans made to get Terry
home
well they uh his the the lady that he
was skiing with she was going to go down
to get the vehicle
and uh and to get to the vehicles on the
other side of the resort and it takes a
little a little while to get there
because you have to go go up a couple
lifts and so so they uh so so she was
gone for quite a while and then and then
the nurse she thought
she thought that I was actually probably
going to go and and take take Terry down
and and the nurse actually told me she
says if he starts throwing up
um
take him directly to the to the ER
because he's got a concussion okay now
uh you then uh let Terry's friend take
him out right
well I I think
I believe later that that
Terry's Terry's friend
um I believe well Terry Terry said that
everything was okay
and that he had everything taken care of
okay and so then as far as getting home
yes
sustained okay what was the context of
okay
um
what was the context where he said
everything's okay yeah yeah he he said
because we're talking about taking him
down yeah
and
um and then they and they they said that
everything was handled and so he was he
didn't need they didn't need me to take
him down now let me just step ahead
um
after February 26 2016. okay
uh when's the next time you actually saw
Terry face to face that summer
um it was probably six months later I'm
just guessing June July
we went down to the to the Cotton Bottom
and is that like a club a beer joint
what is it yeah it's it's it's just a
it's a a just a beer a beer place and
they're they're known for their garlic
burgers
yes okay
pardon me heavy on the garlic or light
on the garlic
um vampires won't get around you
the vampires away all right
and so uh
how long were there with him
oh I'm probably maybe an hour or two
okay uh and did you have another chance
to have a have a lunch with him a garlic
burger with him yes okay and when was
that
that was uh that was probably a couple
weeks later because Joanne really likes
Terry and we used to go down to the
Cotton Bottom and get garlic burgers and
when she found out that I was went down
there with them she had her feelings
were kind of hurt and so we ended up
going down so the three of us went down
do you know very well enough to tell the
jury
what changes might have occurred in
Terry after that accident
I don't know him well enough
he didn't know him well enough before
right no and these in these meetup
groups you'll have a bunch of people
that are that are just there and so if
they're there to ski and they do chat
you know like going up to lift and stuff
like that but but I I don't I've only
I've only met Terry once one-on-one the
other all the other times around in the
ski Meetup Group okay hold on one second
um
you know that oh there's something
two questions
uh
when you were at the hill that day
before the impact
uh were you in any kind of a
a trough or a dip on the hill where you
couldn't see the impact
no okay
now
that report
that we saw here on the screen a few
minutes ago
that wasn't filled out by you was it
no I was filled out by
Eric Christensen
um yes okay no further questions thank
you
drones
I'll be a while do do we want to break
or do you wanna restroom break take
about five ten minutes
5-10 minutes
ready for the jury
no no
we do that
it's this shoulder season between winter
and summer that's the most difficult to
manage in this building
thank you
we'll do
we're ready for the jury
thank you you're welcome to take your
jacket off two if you don't want I'm
good okay thank you
is there any am I allowed to Pivot this
slightly no I think everybody
attention
can I move for admission of 102 to
defense 102 or do we need to do this
when the jury's present
make breakfast
thank you
all right Mr Owens you may proceed but
before we do that just for the record
defense exhibit 102 is received
[Music]
oh thank you Mr Sykes due to the
temperature in here the lawyers have
asked for permission and I've granted it
so that they don't have to wear their
jackets
so if things look a little informal or
we're loosening our our top button
that's why thank you
absolutely if you need to take the jet
uh you know take off a jacket or loosen
a collar looks like you look fairly
comfortable already but if you need to
please feel free
uh Mr Ramon Steve Owens we've met before
correct yes
in fact uh I took a long deposition of
you and a long statement several years
ago true
yes yes
it encompassed about 300 pages of
transcript do you recall that uh yes
did you once
in that deposition say
that's
Eric Christensen told you that Gwyneth
took
Terry out
and no
did did you did you say that today
uh no what I what I meant to say I I get
dyslexic when I get nervous
no he he said that your buddy just took
out with all right I was a little
confused by some of the questioning okay
okay so Christensen always said your
buddy
took out Gwyneth Paltrow right he is all
right did you correct him
no
wouldn't that be the perfect time to say
you are incorrect sir
and I I wasn't he he was yelling and I I
didn't didn't want to get into an
argument with him and didn't want to
even you had
did you finish yeah I didn't want to
have a conversation with him
so there's the the Deer Valley
representative true yes and he's told
you what he believes happened yes and
you didn't say a word no
but seven years later you're saying it
now right
saying what
Vic Gwyneth took out
your buddy not the other way around no
no but he he no he didn't uh
in the Gwyneth Gwyneth uh
uh Terry
what Eric said was your buddy took out
winter that's what he said I I never
said that that uh
the the Terry took out Gwyneth
but you chose not to correct him no
okay and now let's let's turn to uh
defense 87 uh move to admit
any objection what is it
yes
I did give you this binder yesterday
but the one right left
a defense exhibit 87 is received
I'm not sure where everything is
admitted thank you
oh you know what I didn't address this
yet James do you mind if I do that oh I
messed you up
I forgot to address that
did did you record for Terry
a little video of you explaining to
Terry what had happened
yeah Lawrence same day I'm talking the
same same day the same day as as which
date same days of the Collision
no there was no video
did you uh see that Terry I should keep
saying Mr Sanderson so I mean no
disrespect to Mr Sanderson
Mr Sanderson
recorded something
from his friend and eyewitness and sent
it to his daughters
this is defense 102.
uh
do you know what he's talking about
there
I have no idea
you were his friend that was there
and claimed to be an eyewitness true
yes you're the only one yes I don't know
I believe so there wasn't another I I
should say you were the only friend
there in terms of prior knowledge of
Terry Sanderson true
the the prior knowledge at the Collision
site I mean Gwyneth didn't know him
Christensen didn't know him Moses didn't
know him
right yes I was I was the only one that
knew him so something Terry Sanderson
sent to his daughters
said I'm famous and just so you know I
we do have an expert a
binder for the witness and maybe you
could track that down
this is kind of
can you crank your neck and see what I'm
talking about here
are you able to read it from there
yeah
okay
there's no foundation for him to comment
on what Terry said or didn't say or
Senator didn't say it's no Foundation
like overruled I'd like to hear the
question
may approach
so 102 this is so you don't have to
crank your neck
do you know uh whether Terry Sanderson
sent to his daughter something from you
overruled
can you repeat that one more time yes
I'm this I'm seeing if you know anything
about this document no I don't know
anything about any videos here's what
happened from my friend and eyewitness
and then something
you don't know what that is
no I have no idea
defense 102
now
his his daughter responds something to
the effect of I can't believe this is
all on GoPro
do you know what that's referencing I
have no idea
you've never seen a GoPro have you I
know what a GoPro is oh I'm sorry of
this exact case of this Collision
all right let's now go to defense 87
which is the photograph
has been received so in that binder Mr
Ramon that if you go do you see the
little stickers there's one called b87
unless you can personally see this
yourself
may I assist you
so I'm going by these stickers
okay
uh is this you yes it is and who's that
that's Joanne and that's at the first
aid station at the bottom of the hill
I'm guessing I'm not sure
all right I think it was Terry that
produced this so we can ask him uh does
that look like you skiing that day
yes
all right if Mr uh
Sanderson himself says I took this
picture do you dispute it
no I I kind of remember that that photo
you were all smiles there it looks like
true
yeah but I don't uh I don't know when
that photo was taken and uh so I'm
assuming I'm going to represent to you
and it's an admitted exhibit that was at
the first aid station
um
well it's a stipulated exhibit is it not
to admit it but not where it is
well we'll wait till Mr Christensen uh
excuse me Mr Sanderson testifies then
okay
do you dispute that this was taken at
the bottom of the first aid station
I don't know where it was taken
was she one of your skier friends that
day
yes
and and uh
I take it you felt comfortable enough
leaving Terry that you could go complete
your ski day
we went we went back to the truck
that uh Joanne actually did not want to
die did not want to ski after that
and uh so we just we just went back to
the truck
we actually had to go up the up a couple
lifts to get back to the truck because
we were on the other side
okay let's start way back for a minute
um
do you remember some questions about
someone gave us the idea that Miss
Paltrow from the time of the Collision
until the time that she left was about
eight minutes do you remember that
question on Direct
no she was uh she was only there for
about three or four minutes
okay
that's your testimony is that she was
only there three or four minutes
yes and that's from Collision two so
whenever you're ready Collision two uh
and if you could highlight it and make
it bigger your honor
do you remember in your deposition it
was you
who said eight to ten minutes
you can read from it
but it's not an excellent it can't be
shown all I'm doing is asking the
question well but still
stop sustained so you were the one that
said
she was there from Collision to leaving
for eight to ten minutes
yes sir false true or false I don't want
an objection your honored that you need
to decide if he objects that's true that
is true so Mr Sykes let's just hear what
the witness's answer is I think it's a
proper question but but I don't think it
should be interrupting the witness and
dictating what he says here's
well it let me let me just instruct you
uh in a cro this is a cross-examination
it's not like a normal conversation
between two people
and the the questioner is entitled to
ask questions that call for a yes or no
response if you can't answer it with a
yes or a no just indicate that to say I
really can't answer that yes or no
you're done no it's uh did you hear
everything I just said no I thought you
were okay
so this is cross-examination this is not
a normal conversation okay and the
questioner is entitled to ask you
questions that require you to answer
with a yes or no
or if you can't answer it with a yes or
no just tell him I really can't answer
that with a yes or no and then he'll ask
a different question okay and if there's
more to be asked on that topic the other
side will have an opportunity to follow
up later with you okay
have you previously testified under oath
years ago that the time that elapsed
from Collision to miss Paltrow leaving
the scene was 8 to 10 minutes
true or false I can't answer that
do you need to be reminded
we could pull up your deposition
transcript if you
if the answer is uh
you need to be reminded I'm happy to do
that would you like me to do that yes
okay
you can show them a copy of his
deposition and have him look at it uh uh
so this is the
I assumed he would have his transcript
with him you don't I take it no what
and do you have a physical copy of these
hands
thanks what what page James what page is
that
39. judge we need to approach on this
sure
parties please approve
all right
yeah sure on your trial pad
s
page and line reference
right right now we're in direct we're in
the cross-examination so you can go
ahead and show the witness
back and forth
did you happen to read your deposition
like before today
yeah yes
and do you recall what you wrote what
you said in there with regard to this
issue so we're not taking up everyone's
valuable time
there was a lot in that deposition that
question
could you go ahead and read your
transcript and uh I believe if you if
you scroll down
it uh
read it
page 139
line 24 to 25. are you with me no you're
gonna have to walk them through it I'm
not sure how you've how you scroll this
down
yes but I believe that uh I believe that
what you're talking about was taken out
of attic context let's read the question
read can I read the question on page 139
line 24 are you there yes from the time
Gwyneth stood up to the time she skied
away how much time was there
from and your answer go ahead and read
it
sorry I
there you go
yeah and so it uh
I'm gonna read the question again from
the time Gwyneth stood up to the time
she skied away about how much time went
by there read your answer on lines 2-3
and 4. yeah so it says here from the
time she stood up until the and then
that's blocked out and it says I don't
know
something was blocked out
and then then it was cut off and it says
I don't know keep going just start
reading that says maybe 10 minutes or
and and then that's blocked off and so
it doesn't it doesn't uh
line six is it eight to ten minutes and
what your aunt what was your answer on
line eight
uh are you reading this can yes I am
what is it line eight say the three
words there I don't okay it says about
eight minutes
to
your honored that can take place on
redirect which has already been ruled on
okay
let's start from scratch here
Terry was your Facebook buddy Drew
he was on Facebook and you were friends
with him
acquaintance
so on Facebook friends means friends
you're a friend of his on Facebook or do
we have there's people that have a
thousand different friends on Facebook
I I don't even do we have to pull it up
we've got it well you can pull it up if
you'd like I don't I don't even go on
Facebook
so the way this works is I ask a
question okay and if you say yes we go
on and if you say no then we pull it up
okay yes yes he's we're on Facebook
your friends on Facebook yes
you're colorblind true
somewhat is
well this is your deposition yes
yes sorry so one rule of the court is we
can't talk over each other
so I'll I'll complete my full question
then you complete your full answer your
color blind yes
and you don't know the color the outfit
for instance
Miss Paltrow was wearing that day true
true and you don't know the color that
Terry
was wearing that day true
and when they collided it looked like
one person going down is that true yes
you were on the other end of this
courtroom about that far true yes but
you were
you're not just focused on Terry
true
I was focused on Terry well now could
you please repeat that sure you weren't
just focused on Terry right that's not
uh those bolts you were just focused on
Terry that's focused on
I was full yeah yes I was focused on
Terry only on Terry at the top of the
hill I'm just gonna watch Terry is that
your no I no okay you're focused on
other things too yes all right
you have not been in the workforce for
10 years true
true you spend about half your year
scuba diving in about half
skiing
true
bolts
what did you say traveling and scuba
diving have skiing half
false okay but that is that's how you
spend your time those those activities
true
and Terry
strike that Mr Sanderson he
he traveled internationally quite a bit
too didn't he uh well I I can't answer
that do you know how many International
trips he went on after the ski Collision
I can't answer that do you know of any
no
during these six or so days that you had
skied with Mr Sanderson before
that usually involves for instance
having lunch together is that fair
no frequently
um
yes yes so that's time one-on-one
having a burger or something at in the
mid mid Lodge right
that's false okay tell me how it's false
what's we're we're we're in a group of
people all right
and then sometimes after skiing you guys
would go get some drinks and talk Fair
can't answer then
after skiing
would you guys go get drinks together or
eat together during those six visits
did you ever do that
yes
and one of those times was just
one-on-one with the two of you true
false
and one of those was just one-on-one
with you
and your answer
skiing ball balls okay how about uh
after after the Collision did you do
that one-on-one sometimes no
oh yes yes
I'm sorry yes
after the Collision
and you did not observe anything unusual
about him emotionally physically
true
the false ah okay so we'll pull that up
here in just a minute
you knew that Terry had a bad eye I'm
using quotes around that because that's
I'd say Mr Sanderson true
you knew he was 70 years old true
uh
false
you didn't know exactly but you knew he
was about 70 years old true
when you were skiing down that day
you heard a noise
true you didn't know if it was a male or
female voice true
and you turned to look true true
one of the things you were doing
while skiing hopefully is trying to take
care of yourself to make sure you don't
actually crash into someone is that fair
true
this is in let's say the one minute
before the ski Collision
your your focus primarily I assume on
enjoying your day
true
and is it true there was moderate ski
traffic that day
true
there was a picture of the
bandana run you're familiar with it
true or I guess at the time I deposed
you you didn't know the name of it is
that fair
true you were are you you were a
snowbird guy really really true and you
bragged like I had 150 days skiing right
the year before
did you tell me like you had skied 150
days previously in one year that's true
now when you heard a noise
that's what Drew your attention to Terry
true
Terry was wearing a helmet true true
the person he collided with was not
wearing a helmet is that true
that's your memory I don't know
did you tell me she was not wearing a
helmet
I'm not sure I'm not I don't remember
what she was wearing
do you remember previously testifying
that you knew she was not wearing a
helmet
I'm not sure what she was wearing if you
look through the door listen to my
questions did you previously tell me
under oath that she was not wearing a
helmet
I can't answer that and why can't you
because it was because why can't you
tell me that whether you previously told
me that
that she was not wearing a helmet yeah I
wasn't really paying attention what duel
she was wearing
she was not wearing a helmet I mean did
you tell me that previously
I I don't think I don't think so oh boy
I'm gonna make a note of these things
well let's go to page 63.
uh James I think we're gonna have to do
that
all right have you looked at the bottom
of page 63
sorry if I said 53 63
.
bottom of
56 3 is it 53 2 no I'm just asking you
bottom of 63.
have you read that sir the last four
lines
yeah it says above it says I think she
was wearing a hat it's about a helmet so
that's 60 didn't stand up or James can
you just stay exactly right with him
and stay with him bottom of 63 last four
lines
just read those to yourself please it
says now just read it to yourself
yeah the there it says and when I
questioned you about a year and a half
ago you said
she was not wearing
do you remember that that yes and your
answer was yes yes okay that's going
thank you thank you and she was not
wearing goggles either true
I can't answer that sure if did you read
your deposition before this yes like how
many days ago
yes I didn't know what she was I
couldn't remember what she was wearing
can you stay right with them on page 64
at the top can you read page 64 at the
top and she was not wearing goggles
no
okay I'm gonna read the question you
read the answers so let's just start at
the top here okay 64. so is your best
memory she was not wearing a helmet what
was your answer yes
and she was not wearing goggles and you
wrote you said
yes
no it doesn't say that oh
line five
and she was asking questions
and she was not wearing goggles no and I
said is that right and you said yes
and she was not wearing any facial
covering no
is that your testimony that she had no
goggles no helmet and no face nothing
covering her face
at the time of the Collision
is that your testimony today
uh
I can't answer that
all right you've previously tested so
testified under oath true yes
okay I think we're done for a minute
thank you
thank you okay groomed run it was a
groomed run right yes not harder than I
see uh it was
it was very firm okay
so I should specify like so Hills can be
hard or they can be icy which was it
um I I see when it's icy you can go down
the hill with ice skates and uh this
this was very very firm so and so good
conditions right
yes
would you recall that from the time you
heard a scream you can't tell male or
female
you looked
and in a Split Second
then is when uh
you then were upon the Collision site
true your eyes
yes it was about one or two seconds so
in the deposition you said Split Second
do you recall those terms no Split
Second
do we have to look it up or are you
going to deny it uh
a second or two
you're supposed to ask the question get
the answer and then show him the
deposition see if that refreshes his
recollection
so the objection is improper impeachment
this is exactly what I learned in law
school your honor you asked the question
you make sure you have to look it up and
then you look it up go ahead
today I hear you saying one to two
seconds between the screen
and the Collision but in your deposition
you told me Split Second do you agree or
disagree
uh I I could have
overruled
um I I would agree
okay thank you
now
is this your testimony
she plowed into him and he went spread
eagle
head down
true yes hands out skis out yes these
ski stayed on yes
and she went right over him spread eagle
head down
that she was on his back and then her
head's down to downhill yes and then she
slid on top of him
that's your testimony yeah and that when
they is that true yes and then when they
came to arrest uh she was below him on
the hill
yes
[Music]
if he was spread eagle head down toward
the bottom of the hill and his skis
crossed where skis crossed or were they
out no they were out they were not
crossed did you ever go and help him
like
take his skis off no
in the let's say the five seconds before
the Collision
you didn't watch where Gwyneth came from
true true and you didn't watch where
Terry came from
true
you weren't looking at Terry until the
noise and collision
now Terry's a good skier he said and he
skis parallel
true
and he uh the Collision occurred to the
far right if you're going downhill for
the skiers right
true true and there's a bit of a
not a cliff but kind of a Sharp descent
right there true true
gweneth was skiing with an adult male do
you remember
yes and you thought it might be the
Coldplay guy
was that your I didn't know who it was
did you tell me in your deposition you
thought it was the cold plate Coldplay
guide Joanne she's into that stuff and
she said did you tell me your deposition
that it was the Cold Play guy I said it
might have been
and a
her son he saw that her son came over
true
I heard you say that you felt the Deer
Valley instructor was unprofessional did
I hear you sort of say that yes and did
you ever report that to Deer Valley no
did you ever fill out any statement
uh like hey I wanted you to know what I
saw
no
now do you agree your eyesight is not as
good as it was when you were 18.
that truth
Gwyneth got on her feet you saw you you
observed that personally
through
and by then she was like about 10 feet
away from the Collision site
true
and let's pull up
James if you don't mind
exhibit four of
Ramon's deposition
and I don't know what number we've
marked it but I'm going to keep going
until you're ready so let me know
all right we we had to write during your
deposition sort of x's do you recall
this yes X is where things are and uh
this is it if you look to your left
there and if you want to come down
and uh
because I've only admitted like three
what what do we take it down until we
can resolve is it going to be admitted
is it demonstrative what is it
so I was going to establish the
foundation for him and probably move to
admit it
is well why don't you approach yes
is there a stipulation on this exhibit
that it can maybe admitted so okay
defense exhibit 89A is received
all right 89A did you draw this picture
uh yes
I think you can just use the big
microphone there but you can bring the
exhibit to you if you want I don't want
you to hurt your back
um
okay
so can I point out a few things
G stands for Gwyneth is that true
yes
and then
the X below that is Terry you wrote
Terry
that's that's actually above
if you look if you look right here it
says top you're absolutely right that
you're right thank you let's Orient us
so at the top you wrote bottom this is
going to be very confusing for the
transcript but
b-o-t that means bottom
right yes and at the bottom it says top
this is going to screw everyone up true
well it's at the top of the hill and the
bottom of the hill thank you so much so
uh and this represents where they came
to a stop is that fair yes and the right
side it says drop off right that's the
yes
and that's your own handwriting
yes and uh okay so then
you put two x's with Craig
and what does it say does that say four
zero right next to you Craig four zero
what is that
uh yeah 4-0 yes that's 40 feet away
right yeah from the time from the time
of the Collision earlier I heard you say
something like 35 feet but you wrote 40
feet when we previously talked right yes
and then that's where you came to a stop
initially and then it says
Craig and what's that word right there
is Craig after is that what you're
looking at Craig after so you you slid
down at some point is that fair
slit down that where it says 40 that's
where I saw the collision and then I
skied down to where after the Collision
right
so what's the before versus after again
why are there two Craig X's because
that's that's where I I saw the
collision and then after that where it
says Craig after after that I skied down
all right
all right do you stand by your diagram
well I I ended up uh yes yes I do okay
now have you previously met with the
lawyers for Terry Sanderson
uh the previous lawyer yes I've met with
them
did you meet with his previous lawyer
too no
okay I didn't I may have misunderstood
you so you can forget my question uh
you recognize these are not your lawyers
right they're Terry's lawyers true okay
but they've prepared you for your
deposition
they just told me just to go in and just
say the truth just tell your story okay
but you met with them previously without
without me I've met with them
since the accident you've had
several casual conversations with Terry
is that right
true
he's he's someone more than just someone
you skied with
uh that's I actually I went to Once once
I met him in the Cotton Bottom and uh
the twice I met in the Cotton Bottom
then I skied with him two times after
that and ever since that I haven't uh I
haven't seen him
do you want to say
that you could talk Terry could talk to
a wall for three or four hours and have
a good communication good conversation
that's what I was saying he has the gift
for Gab
and that includes prior to the ski
accident
that was yes no I don't know about after
but
um prior to the ski accident he's a he
he likes to talk
all right
is it true that
someone at least asked Terry if he was
all right
after the Collision
that's true and he nodded yes
yes or no
he just he nodded a little bit but he
did uh just nodded he nodded yes
he shook his head a little bit sir do we
have to go to the transcript
if you would be like no I don't want
he nodded a little bit he nodded yes
is the answer yes
he never said he is okay
James could you go show Mr Ramon page
he nodded yes
answer yes do you deny that
I love page Steve
107 line 12.
read the next
10 or 15 verses to get the context
you're on that you can do that during
your redirect
107.
all right I'm gonna read the line why
don't you read it line 12 and 13 and
your answer on line 14.
well it says he nodded yes and question
mark and your answer and a nice I said I
said he nodded your answer sir on line
14 of 107.
don't commentary it just give it to me
it says yes
all right
that's all
on that Terry was complaining of rib
pain after the Collision true true he
was not complaining of any other kind of
pain true
for instance head pain he wasn't saying
my head hurts he was saying my ribs hurt
true
thank you
when you met with Terry these times
after the Collision
I personally could not tell anything
different with Terry
is that true
true
one of your interactions with Terry was
to to go to an elk farm and you point to
an elk and they shoot it for you and
give you the meat is that true
could you repeat that
you bet I can
one of your activities with Terry was to
go to an elk Farm where you point to an
elk and they'd shoot it right there in
front of you and then
uh you buy the meat false oh
am I making this up that you did this
with Terry yes oh well I didn't make it
up from somewhere what did you tell me
about elk meat with Terry well what I
told you was I knew he had some some
kids because they like elk meat and
Terry went to an elk Farm to uh to get a
get an elk and but he he didn't he
didn't shoot it they they shot it for
him okay and then he ended up giving the
meatus to his kids and have you done
that too
I've gotten an elk before yes okay I
think I think I thought those two things
were the same thing but you're saying
that was independent yes thank you
Excuse me while like
try to
wind up here
is this true that uh
Gwyneth where she initially stopped
after the after the Collision she looked
upset
no she just had a blank look on her face
okay we'll find that in just one moment
at some point she slided she slid down a
little further like from 10 feet to then
20 feet
is that right
false
all right
do you remember this in your deposition
so I don't want to go there if we don't
have to
didn't she
move at some point without leaving the
entire scene
from her from her spot where she ended
up after the Collision
could you repeat that please yeah I'm
questioning myself whether we even need
to address this but did did she ski down
a little bit after she stopped in the
Collision
she slid down a few feet
when Terry was going down the hill
before the Collision he was going
straight down with the skis parallel
true yes he was doing small turns
so it was going down
Terry was skiing straight down yes
basically straight man when people is
that your testimony yes he was pretty
much skiing straight down the hill he
wasn't going not pretty much yeah he was
Terry
sorry down I won't talk over you sorry
just tell me if this is the true
statement Terry was skiing straight down
yes
Gwyneth looked shaken up to me
true
yes
even though she according to you had no
helmet on no goggles and no mask or
scarf
you did not recognize her no is that
correct
yes
I take it you don't know what her son
saw Moses
99 or what he heard I do not
now after someone's
uh been hit you understand the idea that
when they go back up skiing they might
be a little
more tentative more cautious more
concerned true like just if I got in a
car accident maybe the next time I'm
driving I'm gonna be extra
maybe less confident is that fair true
it sounds like under your story that you
had to get in between the instructor
because he was so berating
Terry who was down on the ground is that
true
if both
Eric Christiansen
and gwyneth's boyfriend at the time who
was not the Coldplay guy
both say you didn't ski up until
sometime after the Collision do you
disagree with that yes
the eight to ten minute statement you
did make a correction to your deposition
sometime later changing that to three to
four minutes is that true true
but when I was there present test
deposing you with a court reporter you
told me eight to ten
and
I I can't answer that you you made a
change after the deposition was over
is that true
and what
what caused you to make that change like
after it was all over because because it
was taken it was taken at a concert
context if you actually look down to
where I said that a few pages a few
pages down and said that was wrong it
was three to four minutes
within a 25 foot
diameter of the scene
did you ever see any other instructor
come by no
so if Mr Christianson says ski patrol
actually came by
and said are things okay
you deny that
uh yes I never saw a scuten a ski patrol
come by did you ever ask Mr Christianson
hey
I think we ought to get it toboggan here
no
in fact Terry was standing at some point
true true and that was before the ski
instructor left
are true
do you agree some things may have been
said
that you don't remember
among the group
there was no yes or no please
and could you please repeat that sure do
you do you acknowledge you don't have a
perfect memory and that some things may
have been said
that you don't remember
I pretty much remember
so uh just say true or false I have a
false
I've got it I've got to re-ask my
question
I have a perfect memory
go ahead true
true or false overruled
there could there could have been
something that I'd true or false I have
a perfect memory uh Folds
now I'll let you finish your statement
go ahead
there may have been some things that
were said that you don't recall
true
okay we talked about how
Mr Sanderson was spread eagle head
downhill and Gwyneth was spread eagle
head downhill true false
okay
was she it's a compound question so I'm
going to separate was Gwyneth uh spread
eagle down go ahead
no okay and was her head downhill yes
okay
how were her skis they were parallel
okay head downhill
was it straight down like 90 degree
angle or was she a
angle her head was straight down
and uh other skis skis were up above to
the right or to the left or right I'm
not sure whether her skis were pointed
to the rider to the left but she was she
was on her side
at some point
sand uh
Eric Christiansen said or Christensen
apparently have been pronouncing it
wrong for several years
said
your buddy took out one with Paltrow
true true and you went upon hearing that
actually backed up because you were
going to go
to get a closer look is that true true
and when when I saw you doing that
she left
true
you were trying to talk to her and she
did was not responding to you true
at some point in this step today you've
said I wasn't thinking straight I wasn't
I'm not thinking
did you say that today
true
and you were talking about at the time
of the Collision
true
you understand Deer Valley is not on
trial here today
true
that the court dismissed your Valley
did you understand that yes
do you agree with this concept that
there are risks
in just going skiing
true
they're sort of inherent with the
physical outdoor activity
true
those are all of my questions thank you
thank you thank you Mr Owens let's take
a little bit longer recess for
mid-afternoon so we'll take a recess now
thank you
foreign
thank you with Council approach please
um
thank you
foreign
no okay
can you see her I'll let her know okay
thanks we ready for the jury then
they're on their way
thank you
we are
I think they're on their way I told them
when I walked past
there we go
[Music]
all right thank you
Mr Sykes are you ready for redirect I am
Josh let me just
shy
we apologized I'm going to blame it on
the fog
um
Mr Ramona got just about four or five
questions for you briefly
when you looked over
at the you know you heard the screen
over at the Collision
can you tell the jury where Terry's arms
were when he went down
oh they were by his side
not not flung out like this no okay
okay uh
I'm gonna have you turn to page 63 in
your deposition about the helmet
recent clarifying
information on that
I'm going to have Lawrence show you his
on his and computer okay and we're going
to page 63
uh
line 18.
okay
now
I'm going to read the question and then
I'm going to read the answer and ask if
I read it correctly
okay
63 line 18.
and what's she wearing a helmet
your answer I think I don't believe she
was wearing a helmet I think she was
wearing a hat but a helmet didn't Stand
Out was that your answer
correct okay deposition was taken on
November 12 2019
correct oh
uh yeah 12 12 of the 2019. left November
right so three and a half years after
the Collision
yes all right now
um
by the way do you remember how long you
stayed there once if you would remember
how long you were to pose that day
seven and a half hours okay
have you ever been to post before no
first time right yes what a joy right
yeah it was a long day okay uh now
um
Mr Owens asked you
um about nodding okay
I want you to turn to one this is what
he read 107.
17-23
I'll read the whole thing
impeachment
I think he needs to answer a question
and then if there's a contrary answer
then we go to the transcript not
actually not uh on on redirect but yeah
so right now he's rehabilitating based
on your impeachment okay so I'll permit
it
page 107 line 12 Mr Owen's question
was he nodded yes and your answer was
yes
question Terry nodded yes to the
question are you okay your answer yeah
he was trying to get around and uh when
he got up he didn't really ring up and
are you okay with him because he wasn't
okay you could see that I mean if it
wouldn't have been for the mountain host
pulling them up Teddy Terry never would
have uh never wanted to even get up is
that your full answer
true okay and let's go to 109 17-24
okay
and uh the question was
does that sound like your answer he
probably said he was okay
your answer was I don't know what
context this is coming from Terry wasn't
talking
I mean he wasn't it was like we're
having a conversation right now he was
mumbling he didn't he didn't come right
out and say yeah I'm fine I'm doing
great is that your full answer true okay
turn to 110 two through six
okay line two do you agree that one
asked Terry said he was okay your answer
was he never said he was okay
questions so no that's a no yes
and then turn to uh 112 2-12
there wasn't even a question so
can I just read portions of the
transcript I like
this is improper I'd like to
rehabilitate the weather and show the
true context
I've got two more of these and I'm done
I think you need to confirm I mean you
didn't ask him a question on the last
entry oh okay well I'll do it not okay
on page 112 do you see the question
uh by Mr Owens he was nodding yes you
see that oh sorry oh um
yeah no I'm just asking if you see that
if you see that yes the number two okay
yeah and your answer was
yeah he nodded and then there was an
interruption that Mr Owen said yes
uh and your answer was nodded yes as
he's laying there not speaking because
he can't talk
question and the reason I say uh that is
people cannot no not even doesn't help
us answer when he nodded yes he was he
was uh nodding with just like a small
movement you know he wasn't I mean he
couldn't even talk is that your full
answer
true one more
114 4-7
okay
Mr Owens so are you disputing that you
said yes
he said he was okay answer yes
we just started did you dispute that you
said it we need to know what he's
referencing questions Mr Owens just just
a minute there's an objection that that
it's what's the objection that it's not
a complete so he needs to go back to
know what we're talking about do you
dispute that you said it
look
you know you can you can re-cross your
quarter out of context just a minute
by Mr Stephen Owens
so are you disputing that you said yes
he said he was okay answer yes
that's your answer isn't it yes okay
that's all I've done thank you very much
Mr Owens
foreign
spread eagle was that
you testified she that Terry after the
Collision was spread eagle did you not
when he was laying on the ground
right that's what we're talking about
yes when he was laying on the ground he
was he was spread of you
do you agree
that Terry was out cold for several
minutes yes
several is more than two minutes
about two minutes
that's as much as I think I want to say
except we're trying to figure out where
he was
well a little bit of it overruled if
you're going
to the scope of redirect
he was asking about sort of his
positioning so that the entire time he
was out cold
he was spread eagle on the mountain yes
did you do anything for uh no
the helmet thing
let's address it again
sorry for the delay
do you remember telling me that you
thought it was odd she didn't have a
helmet
uh Shirley bottle because we want to
discussed that and he's answered so
overruled true you thought it was odd
Gwyneth Paltrow doesn't have a helmet I
don't recall that
James do you have a citation
I would have noticed a helmet
so no helmet right
yeah I don't recall that oh
all right
you want to go over go over
do you know did I ever saying like
um
what I just said
do you deny that what I just read
I deny it
if you look at if you look at the
deposition I let her sit I wasn't sure
exactly what she had on her what she was
wearing it could have been a hat
I would have noticed the helmet
so no
I I'm just gonna this is uh I I want him
to say it yes that's the question
I would have noticed the helmet
so no helmet right
yeah
can I stop getting interrupted while I'm
doing this your honor when he refers to
the deposition he'll have to give you
the page reference but right now he's
not referring to the deposition
well he may be reading from it but he's
not referring to him
this is a statement that he made to me
do you remember before your deposition
you made a statement
to me
I don't I don't recall do you remember I
came to your house with plaintiff's
lawyers yes we put a little dictaphone
right in front of you and said can we
interview you yes you did and did you
testify truthfully in that interview yes
I do and that interview was far before
the deposition
do you deny saying these words I would
have noticed the helmet
I don't I don't recall that conversation
do you deny saying that
I don't recall that conversation okay
let's go to it then James
so this is exhibit five of the
deposition
it's the interview it's page 31.
sure
all right can you sir read the question
and answer uh
and James the page number is 31.
yeah it says
no commentary just read the words please
um it I says I I think she was wearing a
hat you know because a helmet I would
have noticed the helmet
okay and the next three lines
so no helmet right yeah
and then that's it that's who he is
I said that's a yes and your answer yes
all right sir did you tell the truth
when I asked you that question five
years ago
apparently is
we're moving on sorry 34 I think he said
do you remember you're gonna have to
stay there I'm afraid
he said he was okay
do you remember so testifying five years
ago
he never said he was okay
that wasn't my question my question was
did you answer my question five years
ago
that he was okay
he said he was okay he never said he was
okay he could hardly he could hardly
stand up he could hardly speak so you
deny it ever saying that
did you finish your answer no did we we
you know we James about about two
minutes before the ski patrol came in
and came down he could hardly
um he had a hard time knowing what his
name was I mean it took him four or five
seconds to even know what his name was
and he had no idea where he was even at
your honor my question was and deny
saying it this is
right so
you're taking us
there's no question thank you sorry
all right let's stick it out
he said he was okay
I'm waiting for the question did you say
that
I don't uh
I don't see it here he probably said he
was okay did you say that five years ago
I if I did I probably didn't understand
your question that wasn't my question my
question is did you say that five years
ago
and I think what you're doing is you
think you're taking this stuff out of
context
because I never said he was okay
Terry said yes I'm okay
did you say that
he never said he was okay have you told
me that five years ago
yeah I think what you're doing is I
think you're taking this stuff out of
context
yes he said he was okay do we need to
look it up yes okay James could you get
over there
yes
it's from the interview page 868
okay
can you just read line 10
read it aloud please
yes he said yes he said he was okay
yes he said he was okay
all right did you tell me the truth five
years ago with plaintiff's council
present I think what I don't think I
understood I don't think I understand
you just understood your question
because he was never okay
he could hardly stand
sure
here listen to my question okay
did you tell me the truth five years ago
when you said yes he said he was okay
yes sir I think you're taking this stuff
out of context is what I think
because he was never okay
so all I can do is point to a statement
you gave to both of us with the
transcription recorder present
and saying I'm telling the truth that is
all I can say so that's my only question
was that your answer five years ago
overruled can you answer it just say yes
or no can you answer it with a yes or no
question can you repeat that yeah it's
the same question I'm asking like 10
times but I'm trying to get it clear yes
or no
yes he meaning Eric or excuse me Mr
Sanderson said he was okay
I'm not sure exactly what okay means
we're we're this
yes or no sir I don't know when I don't
know exactly what we were talking about
when he was okay well we can go back and
look
this is page 69. so I know what the
mountain host is going to say he's going
to say I asked him and he said Terry
said yes I'm okay yes
and then he skied away meaning the
mountain hosts and I'm wondering are you
saying that's true or not true
yeah he was yes or no yes he said he was
okay did I correctly read that
I I didn't have the right you said 69
top of 68.68 got it okay
your honor I apologize so tell us where
you're starting which line yeah I don't
want to I don't want to spend any more
time on this
um thank you
does that conclude your questions
okay all right you're what you're
welcome to step down is this witness
under subpoena
and may He testify again in the case
okay
he may testify again
okay so you're still you're still under
the exclusionary rule meaning that you
can't be in the courtroom other than
when you testify okay
okay all right thank you thank you
you may call your next Witness
ES
good afternoon Miss Davidson
if you could walk right up here to the
clerk she will and then if you could
raise your right hand she will swear you
in
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth so help you God
thank you
it's right over here and have a seat
you can move
that binder out of your way
thank you and then we just want to make
sure that you speak toward the
microphone when you when you speak
good afternoon good afternoon would you
state your full name and tell the jury
where you live yes Teresa Carlene
Davidson St George Utah
okay
and you go by Carlene correct I do right
tell the jury
where you were born
where you grew up what your education is
okay I was born in tachikawa Japan my
father was a fighter pilot with the Air
Force and I moved all over the world
during my first 18 years of
life and I ended up in the Salt Lake
Valley where I worked for KSL for a few
years and then ended up at a dental lab
as an accountant and
I have two awesome daughters and seven
beautiful granddaughters that I'm
enjoying in St George Utah
and there's an interesting thing about
you you're you
graduated at least almost from Athens
High School in Athens Greece correct yes
all right
almost graduated yes I I had to come
back for my senior year not not a
pleasant thing senior year in California
but that was talking about Athens Greece
not Athens Georgia right
right exactly no I have a very rich life
I've been very blessed and the
temperature about your about your
training uh from sampling University or
higher education where'd you go and when
uh higher education I went to Brigham
Young University for one year and uh
then after that kind of got my Mrs as
they say and ended up married and
raising children all right
and
with respect to uh
here
uh if you could
explain to the jury how you met
Terry Sanderson okay I was single for a
few years and so that you had a divorce
yes yes divorced from the girl's father
and then unfortunately uh
had another marriage and ended up single
again and got onto a match site and I
happened to recognize a fellow that was
in a picture that Terry was also in the
picture but I had an acquaintance there
that knew him as well so I contacted
this acquaintance and asked him about
this fellow and contacted Terry and
that's how we met
okay
and then about what year was that
2014 sometimes 2014 yeah so it would
have been 2014. and
um how long was your relationship with
you Terry and I prior to the ski
accident ski accident by the way was
February 26 of 2016. correct right we we
dated for about well in a serious
relationship for about 18 months prior
to the accident and then described Terry
during that 18 months uh he was a goer I
had a lot of trouble keeping up with him
he's about five years older than I am
and he was definitely had a lot of
energy a lot of Joyful
he was just a fun loving wanted to uh
play and have a good time in life he was
very energetic very ambitious what are
some of the activities you did during
that time
a lot of hiking a lot of partying to
going to different events throughout the
valley
he uh
gosh we did some traveling the year of
2015 we we went on a cruise we went to
Italy we
also later in the year of 2015 we went
to uh then let's see that was to Belize
and Key West
so we like to travel quite a bit but did
you mentioned dancing they hadn't seen a
lot yes Terry loved to dance okay I can
you mentioned hiking a lot of hiking how
about swimming
yes well I I wasn't the swimmer he was
he has he has a pool in his home
one of those pools that have the
equipment that moves the water and he's
probably swam three times a week
tell me uh pretty much overseas trips uh
what are some of the places you went
with him overseas
the Netherlands we flew into Amsterdam
we went to and then did a cruise out of
Italy and then came back and spent three
weeks in Italy pretty much right
on the cruise we went no no there's
other countries
later we went to
um
Belize and
a lot of
places in the U.S just a little you go
to Spain with him yes yeah that was on
the cruise in when we were in Italy
how about uh Far East Japan any of those
places okay
uh how would you describe his
personality in in the say year and a
half before the ski accident how would
you describe it
very joyful
um like I said a lot of energy he had a
lot of
events that he liked to go to he I
remember his calendar when I was looking
back on pictures and things it was we
were always involved in something he'd
like to volunteer a lot and uh what do
you mean by volunteer what do you
volunteering cystic fibrosis I know he
was a volunteer for different events and
he liked to go and and be involved meet
people meet and greet he was a good
Mentor he liked to Mentor a lot of
younger people and was very good at that
and enjoyed a lot of that a lot of
contact with different people now you
were uh at the time living in St George
yes correct uh and uh
in a year a calendar year how many days
you spend up here with Terry versus down
in St George
most of the calendar was in Salt Lake at
his home we spent a lot of time in the
Salt Lake Area because that's more or
less than 300 days do you think
25 days a month you know
before that whole time period okay
um
you know the the describe him in terms
of uh kindness gentlemeness
communicative that kind of thing
he was very good at communicating he uh
he liked to do that that's one of the
things that we spend a lot of time
talking and engaging and a lot of fun
topics that we like to
explore Terry was an Explorer of all
information he liked to when we when we
were traveling he would always be
reading up on something always you know
looking into things and engaging other
people and gathering information he
liked to do that but he he was a very
joyful happy person I in fact I was
looking back through some of my emails
or my emails pictures and he always had
a smile on his face he had a beautiful
smile that was he was happy person
was he was he kind
very kind describe that the jury
um
would you describe kindness he
engaged with people and I guess the way
his kindness showed through would be
just his patience with talking with
people about different aspects of their
lives and he he just had a gentle nature
he was very easy going that way and
liked people my grandchildren even the
kindness that he had with
opportunities that he had to explore and
speak with them and he just had a gentle
gentleness about him
did you ever have family get-togethers
with his side of the family
would you describe those for the jury
please
one of the first times I remember going
when his granddaughter graduated and uh
with with the whole family and his first
wife was there and I remember his
daughter coming to me and she said thank
you so much for putting up with the
family aspects of it was the first time
that he had been around his former life
for quite some time and it worked out
very well how did he treat her enjoyable
oh fine I was actually saying we had a
great big family reunion family dinner
family fun it worked out very well
now uh
did he ever use alcohol please with you
sir okay and did you ever observe him to
use alcohol to exist
no there would be once in a while once
or twice that we might take a whole
bottle of wine and enjoy it but okay no
not very often
okay when you dated
for about 18 months or close to two
years
were you exclusive yes as far as I knew
was that I say as far as I knew all
right well you're up here quite a bit
yes
um was this a love relationship were you
heading towards marriage or how would
you describe that I I wanted it I wanted
it long term and I was looking forward
to having a long-term relationship with
it I adored him but he was a great guy I
was hoping that it would go long term
so so were you in love with him
absolutely was he in love with you in
your opinion yeah I thought so yes yes
and uh
so uh at this point he's about 70 or so
right that time yes uh at the end of
your relationship I'm sorry
uh just before the accident
uh
February 26 of 2016. how would you
describe Terry's activity level
just like I have very very busy but
whether there wasn't much time that we
didn't have some event that was going on
it's always always involved
I had a hard time keeping up okay
uh did you ever during the 18 months or
so that you were dating him up here 300
days a year
okay General notion to be clumsy or or
accident prone anything like that
not really no no he uh
he was helping me move an estate from my
for my parents I had lost my mother
right before I met Terry and we did a
lot of juggling of my assets from her
estate and he was very helpful with that
in fact
help to move a lot of furniture and
didn't damage too much
he seemed to be pretty capable were you
ever aware that he had a
I think a problem in one of his eyes
that he was not seen were we aware of
that oh absolutely did it ever affect
him in your anything you saw you know
what was odd about that is I half the
time didn't realize that he had a
problem I I never knew which eye it was
I I would have to ask and uh now for the
most part he he covered up very well I
guess if there was an extreme problem I
I wasn't aware of it he drove in fact
thinking about that with my mom's estate
we were moving I had a home in Bountiful
that I sold and we were getting rid of a
lot of the furniture and items in that
home and moving things down to Saint
George and he he drove the big old truck
the 26 26 foot truck I don't know the
week
yeah yeah down to St George down to St
George from Salt Lake and he didn't have
a bit of trouble so I I'm not aware
of the eye situation like I say he
covered up very well
uh
when you were up here
did he do the driving or did he go to
the duty with driving oh he did the
driving you haven't noticed any problem
with him driving
any accidents any bumping into people in
the parking lot or other cars nothing
like that not while I was with him no
okay uh do you recall how would you
characterize his health
during those 18 months or so when you
were before the accident like I say the
hiking the swimming the dancing he had a
lot of energy he seemed to be very
healthy very healthy as far as I know
did he appear to have any chronic
conditions that you were aware of
not that I was aware of I say if there
was anything there I was not aware of it
do you ever complain of a headache
problem
not extreme not anymore so than most of
us do and might get a headache in an
afternoon and need to lie down for a
minute but no how much sleep apnea were
you aware of that
no okay what about depression uh did he
ever complain about being depressed
not during that time no
no what about he didn't have time
okay what about complaining that he was
losing energy you hear that
and
not during that time no I'm talking
about prior to the accident now right
right right yes you ever
uh notice that he was forgetting things
prior to the accident
not not that I noticed no by the way
have you ever testified in court before
this is the first time no this is the
first time it's fun isn't it my hands
are sweaty okay all right um
did you ever uh
you're not a skier correct I used to ski
okay years ago uh did Terry ever talk
about skiing with you prior to oh he
would have loved to have had me ski with
him but no I I have a knee that went out
on me a few years back and I don't ski
anymore what was what was Terry's
attitude towards communion
that was his livelihood in the
wintertime that was one of the reasons
that the distance between St George and
Salt Lake got to be a problem especially
in the wintertime because he did not
want to leave to go to
a warm St George where he could stay up
here and ski how did you find out that
there was a ski accident
I was on my way back here from St George
the day that I think I was on the road
in fact when he called and said I have
been in a ski accident and
I'm injured and but I'll tell you more
about it when we get home I don't think
he wanted to worry me and he said you
know I'll talk about it later did he
ever give you the name the person hit
him I don't think so not at that time no
and that was the same day right
so what did you do after that
I just met him at the house or well not
met him there I think I got there I
arrived there first
and then he came later in the probably
early evening is when he finally got
back describe his condition to the jury
please
looked like a truck had hit him when I
remember him walking in he just was very
disheveled
just looked bad he didn't look like he
felt very well at all he was kind of
wild hair looked like he
yeah he wasn't looking good Ashton gray
his face his coloring and everything he
just looked like he was injured
he was uh
didn't want to talk much at that point
that's why I was kind of trying to get
information from him of what had
happened but he
um
he was cranky he was ornery he just
was tired and wanted to go to bed in
fact that's basically what he did I
wanted to encourage him to go to the
doctor because I was quite concerned by
the way well especially when he said his
ribs were broken he knew his ribs were
broken at that point and then a
concussion I think they had determined
the concussion there at the clinic
slight concussion no maybe not I don't
know if that even happened I just know I
had really sore ribs and looked really
banged up did he talk about whether he
lost Consciousness or not
he did say he lost Consciousness yeah
uh did he tell you how he was taken off
the mountain
he went into toboggan I know that
um
was he able to move around at all very
well not when he got home no he he was a
very sore
Jose he didn't he didn't move well at
all he in fact he went to bed quite
when he got home it might have been like
I say early evening 6 30 7 o'clock and
and he wasn't
up for much after that he just headed to
bed
was he pale Barry
did he complain about weakness
yeah he
he pushed me away basically I felt like
it was just he was withdrawn he didn't
do a lot he The Joy was gone from him
and of course I kept trying to realize
you know he was injured he didn't feel
good
but at the same time he was pushing me
away and at that point I started
spending more time down in St George
um
and the relationship just dissolved
eventually after six months I mean it
just it took some time but it didn't
didn't happen quickly but it just wasn't
good after that he had no joy left in
his life but at the same time I would
have stayed there but he pushed me he
just didn't push me away Did You observe
why he had no joy left in his life what
was going on
that's a good question because not
knowing that you know what he was
dealing with I just figured it was
relationship status things I was trying
to email and talk and put things back
together I haven't always been real
successful in relationships and so I
blamed a lot of it on
that and trying to think it was my fault
or this things were going wrong in the
relationship and now looking back I I
think there was more going on than I
realized
with anything
I had n't been obsessed with before
his health he he felt very conscientious
about or conscious of his um his mental
status and capabilities and it seems
like he just explained that to the
church
um
it's hard after seven years to think
back on on specifics uh he uh
just little things that he would try and
do he felt like he was not capable of
getting things done like he was used to
you know and I know he'd spent a lot of
time on his laptop and he was he was
very involved with the
Fidelity and his finances and different
things he would you know get involved
with his broker and talk about things
and they would do things on the laptops
and they would
um
he
I don't think he felt like he was where
he was
before the accident he just couldn't I
know there was one time silly little
thing but he was putting up a an antenna
on the window of the house Terry was
very conscious of saving a dime he
wanted to you know
fix things and do things on his own and
so he was putting in this antenna and he
got really kind of disgruntled about
putting in a simple antenna on the
window of his living room and
things like that yeah he just
that's what I saw but as far as you know
what he was feeling
um I think he was real discouraged and
that's where he was putting that across
too that he just felt real discouraged
with what he was trying to do the Terry
Sheikh therapy
if you know I think he did
yeah I I I know that yes he did he did
have he had doctor's appointments and
things that he was doing after that
accident I know he was I think he was
struggling with that and trying to
figure out what was going on and uh like
I say Terry hides things really well as
far as you know um
I think he didn't want to let on that he
was struggling but at the same time
being his partner I think he would let
on a little bit more that you know he
was having some issues with things
but I think he kept trying to overcome
as well but was
still hurting did you seek counseling uh
did I yes for what was happening with
Terry well I sought counseling for
myself yes I I explained that
the relationship was falling apart and
uh I was taking on some of that blame
and wanting to find out why and
figure out what was going on with me and
um
so I just sought Counseling in St George
I went to a counselor for a few weeks
uh you told me once you were heartbroken
explain that
I thought I had met the love of my life
when I met Terry
um
we were just
a cute couple and we did great together
and uh
didn't work
he broke my heart when he started
pushing me away and it just
dissolved
how long did you have a relationship how
many months after the accident
about six months six months not six
months
his activity level changed during that
time I mean extremely extremely yes his
activity level changed but that's not
why
I don't think that's why the
relationship fell apart I would just
tell the jury about the change in his
activity level if you would oh he like I
said he was he became like an old man he
didn't want to do anything anymore he
wasn't
just felt like he wasn't capable or just
didn't feel good about it his his Joy
was gone Terry was a joyful person and
his Joy was gone he didn't feel the joy
anymore
his personality changed after the
accident
that's playing
basically that yes he
um
well he became agitated he's like Cherry
was not a man that I ever knew to be um
aggravated agitated
angry
and he became more so in that regard
afterwards he was
yeah little things would get him like
even
a dog my dog was she always would go sit
on his chair in the living room on the
back of his chair and I remember him
coming out one day and he pushed her off
the chair and yelled at her and scolded
her and you know said why are you on my
chair get away and and little things
like that that just didn't seem right he
changed and that was a big change from
the way he acted before
okay and
um
what about his emotional status did that
change
how'd you describe it yeah he
heard
kind of silly but he seemed to cry
easily
um like I get frustrated and tear up and
and that was something that he didn't uh
like I said before he would
I think he wanted to show he was strong
and capable and and afterwards he
showed kind of a weakness to
the effects of everything that was going
on for him
how would you uh
summarize your relationship at about
five months after the accident
kind of summarize that for the jury
he was
very withdrawn at that point that's why
I say he was pushing me away and I don't
know if it maybe was he maybe he thought
that would be the better thing for me in
fact I think he was kind of encouraging
me thinking okay I'm just not the same
person anymore I think you need to move
on with your life go down to St George
of course long distance is hard and I
had my children there and my family and
I wanted to spend time there and would
encourage him to come with me but at
that point for whatever reason he
refused to be a part of that anymore
the jury leave at five and if we're
trying to get this witness done today
we would like the remainder of the time
but if she's coming back tomorrow we
don't have to worry about this
but we see how far we get Mr Sykes
please proceed uh
describe any cognitive changes by the
end of the relationship in terms of
attention concentration
seeming smart Etc all those things
expressing himself verbally and change
in those areas
that's where he withdrew he really
didn't
engage anymore with it even emails and
things when I was gone and the exchange
of
content when we would email back and
forth or even talk it was
wasn't there anymore but it seemed like
he lost intelligence to you
sure yeah yeah I guess he he wasn't he
wasn't the same man so it was hard for
me to say just what specifically
were you working hard to try to save
that relationship absolutely yes I
worked very hard
um
this this
loss of the relationship
do you have any reason to attribute that
to the ski accident do you know I
didn't at first and uh
now looking back and seeing that perhaps
it was a brain injury and perhaps there
were other things going on
I would say so now yeah until the day
before the ski accident was the
relationship strong
um
yeah I I think so yeah we were doing
great thank you
Mr Egan
Miss Davidson pleased to meet you my
name is James Egan I am Council for
defense and I have some questions for
you okay
um
try to be quick we don't have a lot of
time I apologize if they're kind of
rapid fire so you said that Mr Sanderson
hides things really well and I'm
wondering if you think that it's
possible that he he might have hid some
medical conditions not necessarily
intentionally but he he kept them from
you in the way that you described is
that possible probably yeah
so it's is that is it fair to say that
when it comes to
depression or anxiety or a number of
other medical conditions it's possible
that he had them and you didn't know
about it that could be and you wouldn't
dispute if there were medical records to
the uh that no I wouldn't dispute that
no right okay
um
you said I believe that uh
if I heard you correctly
it was your understanding that Mr
Sanderson did not know who hit him at
the time that you first spoke with him
about the accident is that correct
as I recall
and he was also uncertain about what
happened is that right
he lost Consciousness that's all I knew
was yeah so I I yeah I don't know that
other than yeah losing Consciousness and
going on perhaps what someone else said
okay and was that someone else to your
understanding Mr Craig Ramon
yes okay and do you know Craig Ramon I
don't no I don't
um I mean I may have met him once I I
just don't remember him okay
um
was it your understanding from what you
learned about the accident
that Mr Sanderson had been asked if he
was okay by a Deer Valley or some other
ski patrol person and he said that he
was and and that's I think after when we
did start talking about the accident he
had described that yes someone had asked
him you know are you okay and
my understanding was when he
came to and you know how you come to and
you're kind of like shaken and it's like
are you okay and
yeah yeah I I think I'm okay but then
you know five minutes ten minutes down
the road you're like
oh wait a minute my ribs hurt you know
I'm not okay I hurt I don't feel the
same I see and speaking of the ribs
uh
is it true that the ribs were his chief
complaint his pain and his side when you
first talked to him
yes that was his main concern just
because I would try and give him a hug
or try and help him and it's like don't
touch me but I he he didn't look good
either he that's where I became
concerned too and I have a daughter that
has a Nursing degree and I remember
calling her and saying Kara what do I
you know do I need to watch for
something what do I do here and she kind
of briefed me on watching you know as a
person that has a concussion what to do
and so I kind of you know
kept that in my awareness through the
evening but then I insisted that we get
him to the doctor the next day okay as I
recall you you said that you had
encouraged him to go even that the day
before yes but yeah he he just wouldn't
have anything to do with he wanted to go
to bed he was like no I'm going to bed
I'm done I don't feel good I'm just
going to bed and he complained about his
ribs correct oh absolutely but he did he
complain about any head pain you know he
I I'm sure he did yes because that's why
I called my daughter and you know I mean
I knew that the he had a
well whatever it was I guess there was a
suspicion of a concussion at the time I
don't know if it had actually been
diagnosed at the clinic I'm not sure of
that right I know that there was a
suspicion of it and and because he
wasn't feeling well and complained of
just not well he didn't look good and
that's when I wanted to make sure he was
okay
okay these might not be uh in a terribly
organized fashion these next questions
but I'm just trying to again be mindful
of time uh
as I understand that immediately after
the relationship that you had with Mr
Sanderson he moved on to a new
relationship is that correct I
I hate to say it but I kind of
encouraged it at one point because I
think of my jealousy was a little bit
there and and she had been with us
through different concerts and hiking
and doing things and at one point I just
thought you know maybe you and Robin
ought to try it out because you've got a
lot in common but that was my own little
jealousy okay
um
and you you talked about the reasons for
the ending of the relationship early on
you didn't think that it was related to
the accident correct I didn't no I
thought it was my doing just because I
don't do real well in relationships
sorry to hear you say that but in in
terms of uh your own understanding now
you mentioned that you have a new
understanding but that is it fair to say
that special speculation you don't know
what his actual reasons were you haven't
talked to him about those no
and just to be clear do you know
actually and this is the sad part is it
a few probably how many years has it
been seven years
um probably within the last
four years ago maybe during the
deposition time no that was two years
ago at some point he contacted me again
and said he was really sorry for what
had happened and that he felt badly and
tried to get us back together but I've
been in a new relationship and quite
steady and doing well with it so I'm
good now I see
and uh in that conversation did this
accident come up at all
um
okay sorry
as I understand it your understanding of
his medical condition his health
following the accident was primarily
um
primarily derived from those couple
weeks after the accident is that correct
yes as far as I know okay yeah so like
you're up close personal I took care of
him for the first couple of weeks right
after I stayed there for about I think
two weeks close to two weeks right and
and so that up close personal
understanding of his medical condition
is is limited to those weeks is that
correct
that and then the the few months after
that that we were together
um yeah correct though what I'm trying
to get to no it's okay what I'm trying
to get to is in your deposition
um you made a distinction about um
uh the the understanding you had at the
time and then those of those few first
few weeks and that later you became uh
um
I think focused on the relationship and
not on his health is I think how you put
it does that sound fair
stained okay I apologize I'm trying to
just be quick so sir
let's see um would it be fair to say
that the your understanding of his
health
um
was limited after those few weeks
because you didn't see him as as
frequently okay
and I can't get the deposition
transcript out and bring it to you and
we could look at the actual if you don't
recall okay yeah you're just saying that
that time that I was taking care of him
that would be the limitation of my
understanding what his health conditions
were
yeah that you had a good understanding
for those few weeks but then after that
you didn't have as good an understanding
because you were focused on other things
and he had probably thought that was
accurate okay that's fair all right
that's fair okay I didn't answer asked a
question that's right I'm glad that we
got to that sir thank you
um
so you mentioned earlier I believe that
he kind of became like an old man do you
remember that testimony yeah absolutely
um would it surprise you if he had told
someone uh maybe even a doctor a number
of weeks before the accident that he'd
gotten old all of a sudden oh before the
accident even yeah I'm not aware of that
okay but would that surprise you if he
had said that yes okay
it would I guess because yeah we
as I recall we were quite active up
until
that time
but then again I had been I had been
away for a while I had been in St George
for some time I don't know there again
that's why I'm trying to think it's been
so long
um sure because I was coming back when
the accident had occurred I was just
coming back so I had been away for a
couple of weeks prior to that right okay
thank you
um
just in this same vein would it be
surprising to you if someone had uh said
that he would again before the accident
routinely walk into walls oh
that surprises me or what about it uh
you mentioned the vision issue which you
did have an understanding of correct
absolutely so what did you ever observe
him asking someone uh standing on the
right side of his vision to move so that
he could see them better oh no okay
um
were you aware of uh
any medical event like a stroke-like
event that might have uh impacted him
and he would have had to get MRIs and
that sort of thing for prior to the
accident I don't remember okay that's
that's okay if that's the truth that's
fine
um
and I one of the reasons I ask it is
that I'm wondering if you know whether
that sort of thing was the reason that
he retired from his profession oh
that surprises me not well I'm I'm just
asking no no not at all and then
um
did he ever talk about uh adjusting his
skiing to one side of the slope so that
he could avoid hitting people never
not in my knowledge no well or what
about just being picky about the days
that he skied so that he could avoid
um bad lighting oh
this is all new information never never
heard of it I'm not giving you
information I'm just asking if it would
be something you would say or you would
would have seen in him okay
um
okay I believe I am done but I'm going
to look at one more thing to see if I
need
I need it may have been covered
oh just I wanted to be clear about this
during those weeks just after the
accident as I understand it you were the
only one with him during those weeks is
that right yes
you were the one caring for him and
communicating with him yes and as you
understood stand it he was withdrawn
from all other people during that time
as far as I know yes I don't know as far
as conversations with these on the phone
or emails or whatever but yes physically
I was the only one there
okay that's all my questions thank you
thank you
sure
hearing something about okay do you know
have you ever had a broken rib
no have you known people that have yes
they tell you it's pretty painful very
yeah so you think a person with four
broken ribs can tell someone they're
okay
but that's
uh
uh let me ask you uh
so you can try to box you in with the
two weeks of medical care but uh you you
were still coming up 25 days a month
after the accident I want you
not as frequently not as frequently but
yes I was still spending a lot of time
up there of course as I was still trying
to maintain a relationship in the in the
three months after the accident how many
days you think you spend up here or well
let me
they're again looking back through
photos that's the only thing I can go
through
um we I had a
we still spend a lot of time together in
fact I even encouraged him to come down
to a birthday party where my
granddaughters in Cedar City and so I
was like I say looking at photos and
another one we went to his
um his granddaughter's graduation in
Washington in June of that year after
the accident but uh so yes we spent a
lot of time together still traveling and
doing what we were trying to do but it
just yeah it was Necessities necessity
travel not enjoyment travel in the six
months after the accident do you think
you had a pretty good idea of what kind
of person you're changed into
what kind of problems he was having
I yes I I saw a big difference
Mr Egan no question all right
you may step down thank you
why don't you just have a seat I'm going
to excuse the jury first so we're going
to go ahead and recess at this time and
we'll reconvene tomorrow morning at 9 00
a.m thank you
oh let me I have to do this I have to
remind you of your obligation not to as
as
as much as you might be tempted not to
do any of your own investigation not to
review anything on the Internet or
anywhere else not to communicate with
anyone about the case including your
fellow jurors and remember that the
evidence will be coming in one piece at
a time and that you need to keep an open
mind until you hear all of the evidence
so thank you for your attention today
you may step down thank you
sure so paragraph four at the end of
Court proceeding Spectators shall remain
in the courtroom until the judge the
jury and the parties have withdrawn
the bailiff gives permission to leave do
you mind if we excuse our parties who
have been here our clients I don't know
okay so you're free to go
is there anything that the lawyers need
to address right now
it'd be nice to get our monitors working
is that a possibility or week did we
give up
that's up to you it sounds like it's
we're giving up is that true
okay and then our witness as I mentioned
before there is a very large monitor in
the courtroom next to us and if it's not
being I think tomorrow it'll be used by
the commissioner yeah
well there is there is one for this room
so we have a large monitor that could be
rolled in front of that screen and used
um if you'd like to addition to that
screen yeah there's a large television
monitor with an HDMI
HDMI port on it and we put it where
again I'm sorry well you can put it
where that screen is so you could roll
it back and forth as necessary
I like
a gentlemen uh well and Kristen sorry uh
where if if they're offering a big
screen do we want it or do we don't want
it
let me bring it in right now and you can
take a look at it okay and then we we
just need to leave I don't know
we're abandoning it we like that better
thank you okay and then a witness lineup
for tomorrow from the plaintiffs please
witness lineup for tomorrow
I think it's Sam Poland yeah
we gave him this list so this is the
list they gave me and Wendell Gibby Sam
Goldstein both in the morning is that
sound right
uh give you in the morning and going
through the afternoon
we have two other
before and after Witnesses we hope will
be here on time
and we will fill in
with them
as we are able thank you so daughter
Shay Shay and Polly grashem and then
brother of son-in-law marks
are those three are those three planning
to go tomorrow
this coming Friday thank you for that so
it sounds like four Witnesses tomorrow
Gibby Goldstein Shay and Paulie
how we go um
we hope we'll have four Witnesses
tomorrow when I'm flying in from Montana
and the other one Washington so
but no more than those four
well
told him this we've advised the court we
may call Gwyneth Paltrow
we don't want there to be that time
in the courtroom so that's there's a
question why I'm asking your honor
because
what's the lineup I don't want coiness I
wanted this hey there's not quite a
shirt okay so times I gave you this
three weeks ago you sat in my conference
room I showed you my trial plan Gibby
Goldstein Shay Holly and
we notified you
yeah can I just hit a yes from that like
those are the four plans we notified him
that we could come
we afterwards that time so there's a
chance you may call for tomorrow
possibly we're planning on calling her
Friday that's our plan okay so at those
four I mean can we just get a yes five
possibly gwena that's why
no I mean I guess we don't in all
fairness Mr Owens if if he doesn't have
a witness available then we're then he's
eating up his trial time with dead time
I no I get it but like when is Shea
coming when are you planning on it we're
hoping to have them tomorrow morning
later or tomorrow afternoon now you know
the one Shea doesn't get into one Paulie
Paulie I think is
coming in the morning but I don't know
for sure
you don't know when your witness is
coming
sir
we're hoping to have them tomorrow
that's our plan
all right these people are out of town
the pre-trial the pre-trial order
requires that that one side disclosed to
the other who they're planning to call
the next day I guess it doesn't specify
the order or the times just be prepared
for those possible five witnesses right
it's just like we don't know when it's
always coming even coming
that seems odd
well that's that's what we have that's
what we have right now
um and and Council I guess what I'm
asking is that as soon as you know when
a witness is arriving that you let the
other side know
okay believe me if I had a what did um
so she's gonna try to come right up here
after that and be available
early-ish afternoon
uh there's Goldstein in the afternoon at
1 30. that's the plan okay thank you he
only has one day
all right anything else for this
afternoon
take care of that cough Mr Sykes thank
you I offered him I meant
we're now we're now cut back to a pack
today I'll give them this in the morning
thank you for now adjourned thank you